[Musique]
emmanuel macron présente ses priorités
pour la présidence française du conseil
de l'union européenne
elle démarre le 1er janvier le chef de
l'état tient une conférence de presse
rendez vous a été fixé aux journalistes
à 16 heures à l'elysée une prise de
parole que nous suivons en direct sur
helpe et tous
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france c'est la
deuxième fois depuis le début de son
camp qui marque emmanuel macron
s'adresse aux journalistes le chef de
l'état va s'exprimer depuis l'elysée
pour présenter ses objectifs pour
l'europe à trois semaines de la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne
elle interviendra donc en pleine
campagne présidentielle
en échange avec la presse qui sera donc
l'occasion d'interroger le président
sortant sur sa candidature pas encore
confirmé on retrouve devant l'elysée
notre reporter katia technique
un katia c'est une conférence au
dispositif particulier pour emmanuel
macron face à une centaine de
journalistes
et oui en effet ce pour des annonces qui
ont trait à la présidence française de
l'union européenne qui démarre le 1er
janvier c'est une première depuis 2008
un moment très important du mandat d'
emmanuel macron d'où ce dispositif très
particulier alors le chef de l'état
comme vous le disiez va répondre à une
centaine de journalistes dans la salle
des fêtes de l'elysée est au centre de
son intervention cette présidence
française sachant qu emmanuel macron ce
n'est pas un mystère a toujours
manifesté sa volonté de bâtir une europe
forte au prix de réformes importantes et
aujourd'hui le président français veut
être des résultats il veut des objets
remplir des objectifs pour ces six mois
cruciaux et donc des négociations âpres
à sont à prévoir car le consensus est
difficile à obtenir au sein de l'union
alors quel sujet va-t-il aborder bien il
en a dévoilé il y à peu avec un
programme qui est nommé relance
puissance et appartenance à leur
appartenance pourquoi eh bien le
président français estime que de
nombreux européens ne se sentent plus
appartenir à l'europe il faut donc
soigner cet aspect puissance car il
souhaite fortifiée une europe souveraine
qui fera ses propres choix militaires
technologique culturel et de valeurs et
là évidemment on retrouve l'idée d'une
défense européenne qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité
autre sujet phare l'écologie avec la
question de la préservation du climat et
l'idée d'une taxe carbone aux frontières
et puis également des dossiers complexes
comme l'institution d'un salaire minimum
européen
c'est un dossier qui est déjà ouvert
travailler mais est-ce qu'il sera
bouclée avant la fin de la présidence
française et bien on ne sait pas et donc
tout ça a pour but d'éviter le dumping
social autre question qu'on se pose qui
n'a rien à voir avec la présidence de
l'union européenne mais la présidence de
la france emmanuel macron en sera-t-il
président est bâti l'annoncé aujourd'hui
ou l'évoqué bien nous en saurons plus
d'ici quelques minutes merci beaucoup
katia penny technique devant l'elysée où
donc doit commencer la conférence de
presse des manuels macron avec nous pour
suivre cette prise de parole du chef de
l'état françois poulet mathis bonjour
merci d'être en direct sur arte france
est journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes et ça tombe
bien vous allez nous expliquer à quoi
sert le conseil de l'union européenne
qu'est ce que c'est et qu'elles sont
quelle est la mission du président
tournant et or il faut bien comprendre
que cette présidence tournante qui
existait avant a été légèrement modifiée
depuis le traité de lisbonne il s'agit
essentiellement pour chaque pays c'est à
dire les 27 pays de diriger tous les
conseils des ministres agriculture
économie intérieure tous ses conseils me
sont animés par un pays pendant six mois
pendant cette période c'est très
important parce que ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que chaque pays qui préside
l'union européenne instant brain et
maître de l'agenda et donc anime ces
discussions et doit rechercher le
consensus c'est très important un peu
moins important depuis 2009 depuis le
traité de lisbonne depuis que lé conseil
européen et le conseil général pour
celle des affaires étrangères ne se ne
sont plus dirigés par le pays qui
préside l'union mais par un personnage
qui a été nommé par le tennessee bonne
il s'agit de charles michel qui est
président du conseil européen et puis
borel qui est ministre des affaires
étrangères de l'union mais tous les
autres conseils c'est déjà ce domaine
c'est le pays qui assure la présidence
qu'il fixe la l'ordre du jour qui fixe
l'agenda et ça c'est très important
c'est important aussi un double titre je
sais pas si vous vous souvenez mais lors
de la présidence de la france ou de
sarkozy c'est ce rendez vous avait été
très important puisque sarkozy avait
requis une certaine aura deux par la
présidence française qu'on considère
d'une certaine manière comme ayant été
réussie donc pour emmanuel macron sur
rendez vous est très important double
chance c'est que d'une part c'est très
important parce que il va retrouver une
son souffle européen qui lui est
naturelle mais c'est aussi important
parce que les conditions ont changé
d'abord il ya un nouve un nouveau
gouvernement en allemagne social
démocrate allié avec les écologistes ils
lui est fondamentalement pro-européen et
puis aussi parce que il ne compagne
présidentielle en france nice annonce
est pour emmanuel braun mouse est une
occasion rêvée effectivement pour entrer
dans la campagne dire parce que
effectivement
la réalité les lacets que mâcon va
pouvoir affirmer 1,4 affirmé une
stratégie sur un domaine aussi important
que l'europe et cela sans être
directement impliqué dans la campagne
dans la mesure où il n'a pas encore
présenté sa candidature
d'ailleurs
l'une de ses principales opposantes qui
prévalait et pécresse aujourd'hui même a
publié une tribune libre dans laquelle
elle s'empresse elle aussi de fixer ses
priorités pour l'europe qui d'ailleurs
c'est assez chaud provenant sont assez
proches même très proche de celle
d'emmanuel macro donc j'ai vraiment un
rendez vous assez important pour les
manuels macro et pendant six mois c'est
donc la france qui mettra en avant qui
gérera l'agenda de l'union européenne et
si on vous comprend bien ce que la
france peut avoir une réelle influence
elle a une influence à double titre elle
a une influence d'abord parce que c'est
un grand pays c'est un pays fondateur de
l'union européenne dont toutes
orientations de la france comme
d'ailleurs de l'allemagne sont des
orientations extrêmement importante mais
c'est aussi important parce que à voir
l'agenda avoir l'ordre du jour la bêtise
sur l'ordre du jour c'est aussi
reprendre l'initiative et pouvoir avoir
une influence sur l'ensemble des pays
c'est très important parce que si la
france veut éviter de donner des leçons
c'est un petit peu le reproche qu'on lui
fait là elle va se met dans la position
pendant un arbitre mais d'un animateur
d'un animateur de club de 27 et ça pour
emmanuel mâcon c'est vraiment un pari
est un pari important qu'il peut gagner
mais le problème effectivement ce qu'il
y a toujours ce rendez vous des
élections présidentielles qui va casser
un petit peu le rythme ça va le cacher
mais pas tant que ça parce que on peut
considérer que les principaux opposants
d'emmanuel maquereau à la présidentielle
et je citais notamment valérie pécresse
sont très proches sur le plan des
actions et des priorités européennes
donc je pense emmanuel mâcon va fixer
des priorités on a dit tout à l'heure il
s'agit de la relance économique
il s'agit de la puissance de l'europe
à l'extérieur et à l'intérieur et aussi
de l'appartenance du sentiment
d'appartenance à leur créer et
promouvoir ce véritable citoyenneté
européenne sur lequel il milite depuis
des années déjà alors vous évoquiez la
dernière présidente présidence française
du conseil de l'union européenne
s'étaient donc avec nicolas sarkozy
d'une façon générale et ce qu'elles ont
marqué c'est présidence française à la
tête de lieux
oui parce que en général lorsqu'un pays
exerce la présidence parfois et bien
souvent il est mieux compris de
l'ensemble des partenaires lorsqu'on est
un pays tout seul est notoirement
lorsqu'on états unis relativement
puissant comme la france ou l'allemagne
on a tendance à se méfier
en attendant ce que je disais tout à
l'heure à ce métier de donner des leçons
et c'est lorsqu'on en assure la
présidence ont un peu plus respectés et
parfois on est un peu plus compris et je
pense que le fait qu' il y aura beaucoup
de manifestations autour de la
présidence française il ya aussi
beaucoup de déplacements à l'étranger
pour animer cette présidence c'est que
les la compréhension risque d'être un
peu meilleur entre les partenaires
européens des 27 partenaires européens
et la france qui en a besoin parce que
la france est expliqué ces derniers
temps effectivement pour prendre des
positions à peut trancher là la france a
une chance une charge bien je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure qu'il ya un nouveau
partenaire allemand qui est d'ailleurs
fortement pro européen et ça c'est très
important pour la présidence française
et puis une chose aussi parce que
aujourd'hui les français ne conteste
plus l'appartenance à l'union européenne
et ça c'est un point très important sur
lequel d'ailleurs d'achat puis emmanuel
macron probablement dans un instant
parce qu'il va présenter ses priorités
et vous dirais qu'il ya un réel bénéfice
pour le président sortant à prendre la
tête du conseil de l'union européenne à
quelques mois de la présidentielle
bien sûr il ya un bénéfice dans la
mesure où il va fixer un cap il va
donner une orientation générale on sait
très bien que la manière les élections
présidentielles où la campagne j'ai
l'échec présidentiel se présentent
actuellement en france c'est de manière
très nationale l'enjeu apparaît très
nationale en fixant des orientations et
surtout des ambitions à caractère europe
1 effectivement le président le me donne
une dimension que les autres candidats
jusqu'ici ne donnait pas soit qu'ils
étaient fondamentalement anti européens
soucieux de voir l'europe soit acquitté
soit cité nord de la france soit quitter
l'europe soit alors quitté les traités
soit alors méfiance généralisée du un
grand nombre d'opposants en france sur
la nécessité de 7 ans on comprend pas
toujours là ma cour a toujours été très
clair pour lui pour la france l'avenir
de la france à l'été européenne elle
peut pas être en dehors de leur ai donc
ça il va la firme est effectivement ça
de lui ni mention un peu plus grande
oui si elle peut servir le probable
candidat
macron le président sortant et probable
candidat à sa réélection si elle peut
servir sa candidature en quoi est ce que
la présidence française peut-elle servir
lieu
elle peut servir l'union européenne dans
la mesure où la france sera en capacité
effectivement de faire des propositions
et d'avoir un réel rôle d'efficacité
dans des domaines aussi importants que
la relance économique
je donne quand même un exemple qui n'est
pas anodin qui le fait que l'actuel
chance le nouveau chancelier d'allemagne
général olaf scholz et l ancien ministre
de l'économie dit angela merkel et c'est
bien lui qui finalement avec
déverrouiller le système économique
européen en permettant cette es16 cette
acceptation d'un emprunt oui tu as lease
et ce qui est une véritable révolution
sur le plan européen
toute cette solidarité affirmée en
matière financière surtout pour relancer
la relance économique ça c'est quelque
chose de fondamental
donc sur ce plan là effectivement
l'europe a bénéficié de cet accord
franco-allemand toutes les initiatives
que va lancer probablement la présidence
française et notamment en matière
d'immigration parce que là aussi que ce
soit les migrations que ce soit la santé
ces deux domaines où on attend l'europe
qu'elle soit un peu plus efficace
qu'elle et jusqu'à maintenant et bien là
la france peut être en capacité
effectivement de combat quoi ses
partenaires de faire un petit peu un
bond en avant dans la coordination et
peut-être même
aller plus loin que la coordination des
politiques surtout en matière de chanter
est ado mais jusqu'à maintenant qu'ils
n'étaient pas un domaine européen est
bien en matière de santé mais aussi en
matière de l'immigration de faire un
petit peu avant un bond en avant pour
répondre notamment aux critiques d'un
manque d'efficacité de l'europe je suis
un sujet aussi important que celui là en
attendant que la prise de parole à des
manuels à macron dans cette salle des
fêtes de l'elysée tout le monde est
assis tout le monde attend le chef de
l'état il devrait arriver au pupitre
d'ici quelques instants avant peut-être
françois poule et mathis de ce contexte
de la prise de présidence française de
l'union européenne quels sont les
dossiers qui attendent la france
allait aussi je le disais il ya bien sûr
la migration la refonte du système
schengen qui a montré ses faiblesses
donc il faut revoir à kibuye système là
et notamment les problèmes liés au droit
d'asile la manière dont on gère les flux
migratoires
le problème de la cause du contrôle aux
frontières relancer peut-être renforcer
l' agence frontex et puis en matière
économique il faut relancer une
autonomie européenne faire revenir des
productions ou quiche se sont éloignés
de loeb pour redonner une impulsion
économique à l'industrie européenne en
matière par exemple de médicaments je
conçois pour les maths il sa place au
direct direct sur les lises emmanuel
macron s'apprête à prendre la parole le
chef de l'état qui présente donc son
projet pour la présidence française de
l'union européenne c'est parti 1er
janvier on écoute le chef de l'état
nistre mesdames messieurs
heureux de vous retrouver pour cette
conférence de presse dédiée à la
présidence française du conseil européen
qui commencera au 1er janvier prochain
et qui est un moment historique en ce
qu'il est rare à lui seul puisque dans
l'europe à 27 la france n'exerce en
effet cette présidence qu'une fois tous
les 13 ans tous les 13 ans elle a cette
responsabilité
de porter des ambitions pour l'europe
tout en nous inscrivons pleinement dans
le collectif européen et c'est tout à la
fois un rôle qui consiste
à pousser évidemment nos priorités nos
ambitions nom propre agenda mais
également à être les dépositaires une
forme d'harmonie est donc d'accord
européen qui doivent émerger durant ces
six mois et donc à partir du 1er janvier
2022 nous aurons à vivre ce temps dans
un moment particulier que je veux
qualifier ici avant qu'on entre riom
dans le fond de cette présidence
celui d'abord d'une crise sanitaire qui
se poursuit qui nous a durement frappé
depuis trente deux ans celui évidemment
du bouleversement climatique
la révolution numérique
d'inégalités mondiale croissante danger
migratoire exacerbée par les
manipulations de certains état de
tentatives de déstabilisation de nos
démocraties et de montée de tension
jusque dans notre voisinage le plus
direct
et donc face à toutes ces crises qui
percute l'europe nombreux sont ceux qui
voudraient ne s'en remettre que seule
nation
ces nations sont notre force notre
fierté mais l'unité européenne et leur
complément indispensable
et ce moment exige de nous à cet égard
plus d'efficacité plus d'affirmations
plus d'autonomie plus d'indépendance et
il dit je crois avant toute chose le
besoin de nous unir nous européens c'est
ce que nous avons cherché à traduire la
fois dans le le contenu même de ce que
cette présidence portera
mais également à travers
l'emblème et les quelques éléments
symboliques qui vont caractériser cette
présidence et je vais peut-être tout de
suite avant de rentrer sur le fond de
notre programme demandé au secrétaire
d'état aux affaires européennes qui
auprès du ministre de l'europe et des
affaires européennes a conduit ces
travaux de nous présenter tout à la fois
cet emblème mais également la nouvelle
pièce et je salue ici la présence notre
graveur et la monnaie
ici présentes qui à travers de son
directeur général monsieur schwartz ont
travaillé sur ce sujet depuis de longs
mois et également nous présenter la
carte de ces travaux à travers
notre pays
merci monsieur le dans la république
nous allons vivre en effet un moment
très important pour notre pays je crois
pour toute l'union européenne ce sont
bien sûr des chantiers politiques tes
priorités législatives
l'ambitieux que vous allez présenter
dans quelques instants aux français mais
ce sont aussi des symboles une identité
des messages que nous portons à travers
un certain nombre d'exemples très
concrets et je vous propose de découvrir
sans plus attendre l'emblème que nous
avons retenu pour la présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne
[Musique]
cet emblème que nous avons choisie pour
six mois représente initiale de l'emi
europe habillés des couleurs de la
france des étoiles non européenne nous
n'avons eu ni une flèche porte un
message
d'ambition pouvoir tenir qui consiste à
aller de l'avant face aux tentations du
repli ou parfois du renoncement ce
modèle de l'europe nous le défendons
sous votre autorité monsieur prendre la
république depuis quatre ans pour une
europe plus souveraine plus unie plus
démocratique nous avons essayé de le
résumer de résumer les priorités que
vous allez présenter aussi dans une
devise que je vous propose
qu'immédiatement deux voire trois mots
qui incarne cette ambition européenne
la relance la puissance et
l'appartenance
la relance parce que nous sommes encore
dans un moment de crise et nous
construisons au niveau européen une
réponse économique le réarmement
économique de l'europe est encore plus
que jamais nécessaire nous essaierons le
faire avancer la puissance parce qu'elle
est la condition du modèle européen que
nous devons préserver et promouvoir dans
le monde et puis l'appartenance car
aucun projet politique ne saurait durer
sans un sentiment collectif de
participer à une aventure importante ce
sont des valeurs partager une culture
que nous avons en commun une histoire
qui me relie l épais pour l'avenir
nous avons aussi souhaité vous avez
saluer monsieur prendre la république le
directeur général de la monnaie de paris
et le graveur général que je salue à mon
tour nous avons souhaité un objet très
simple si je peux le dire ainsi sonnant
et trébuchant pour incarner cette
président je vous propose de découvrir
une nouvelle pièce de deux euros
je crois que normalement chacun la
normale en chacun en a un exemple
frapper chez le directeur général
cette pièce de deux euros est important
d'abord parce que c'est la première fois
depuis l'entrée en fonction dans les
portefeuilles des français des européens
des pièces en euros qu'en france nous
changeons le dessin de cette pièce bien
sûr cela consiste à marquer
l'anniversaire de la monnaie unique 2022
seront aussi les 20 ans de l'euro les
français comme les européens y sont
attachés ils sont très attachés même
plus que jamais ils soutiennent la
monnaie unique en font un élément de
stabilité de protection d'attractivité
de nos économies qui nous a protégés
aussi pendant la crise sur ce symbole
qui a été dessiné par joachim gimenez le
graveur général de la monnaie de paris
je crois que vous voyons une continuité
avec les pièces que nous avons mais
aussi une modernisation écologique
notamment les devises la devise de la
république qui se retrouve le chêne et
l'olivier la force et la sagesse
jacinto ciel c'est un symbole qui ne
sera pas simplement commémoratif ce sera
une vraie pièce qu'il est le 1er janvier
2022 sera en circulation qui est frappée
à pessac au coeur de la gironde comme
les premiers rôles ont été depuis 24 ans
et qui sera utilisable par chacun
d'entre nous comme un signe de cette
europe que nous avons auprès de nous
dans notre quotidien
et puis cette europe monsieur le
président vous avez voulu qu'elle soit
incarnée qu'elle souhaite aussi
enracinée dans toute la france dans les
territoires de l'hexagone et des
outre-mer et nous aurons pendant cette
présidence française ce semestre de
présidence française dans toutes les
régions de france nous voyons ici plus
de vingt réunions ministérielles qui
seront accueillis dans tous les domaines
dans toutes les régions l'occasion de
montrer cette europe au plus près de
valoriser aussi notre patrimoine notre
culture sur tous les thèmes au cours des
semaines qui viennent vous préciserez
aussi je crois monsieur le président un
certain nombre d'événements que vous
présiderait à votre niveau une europe
des symboles de l'identité de la
proximité c'est ce que nous avons
cherché un carnet à travers ces éléments
je veux saluer à cette occasion monsieur
le présente toutes les équipes qui
partout au sein de l'état ont déjà fait
un travail exceptionnel pour préparer ce
moment qui est une responsabilité et un
honneur important pour notre pays je
vous remercie merci beaucoup merci pour
pour cela à nouveau merci à la monnaie
de paris à l'ensemble des équipes qui
ont oeuvré pendant des mois et je vais à
mon tour remercié vraiment le ministre
de l'europe des affaires étrangères et
secrétaire d'état ainsi que l'ensemble
des équipes de diplomates qui ont oeuvré
à leur côté pour préparer cette
présidence le secrétariat général son
secrétaire général qui depuis plusieurs
mois non préparés évidemment l'ensemble
des diplomates au quai d'orsay notre
représentation permanente à bruxelles et
ses équipes le secrétariat général aux
affaires européennes auprès du premier
ministre car cette tâche vous le voyez
vous l'avez vu un instant occupe aussi
beaucoup de politiques publiques
françaises est évidemment les
différentes équipes diplomatiques aussi
à matignon et à l'elysée et l'ensemble
des ministres je remercie les ministres
ici présents aujourd'hui mais c'est un
travail profondément interministériel
qui a occupé le gouvernement pendant
plusieurs mois et qui est aussi le fruit
d'un travail intense du gouvernement
depuis plusieurs mois pour préparer
cette présidence alors s'il fallait
résumer en une phrase
l'objectif de cette présidence qui
s'étendra du 1er janvier au 30 juin je
dirais que nous devons passer d'une
europe de coopération à l'intérieur de
nos frontières à une europe puissante
dans le monde pleinement souveraine
libre de ses choix et maître de son
destin et c'est ça l'objectif que nous
devons poursuivre pour la première fois
en effet depuis près d'un demi-siècle
des questions existentielles nous sont
posées sur le plan climatique sur le
plan technologique
sur le plan géopolitique qui impose et
c'est ce que nous préparons déjà vous le
savez depuis plusieurs années le
profondément transformé notre
organisation de nous doter d'une
ambition nouvelle
j'avais eu l'occasion de présenter cet
agenda dès l'automne 2010 est à la
sorbonne et nous avons déjà parachever
beaucoup des objectifs qui avaient été
alors annoncée
mais ce travail aujourd'hui est rendu
encore plus indispensable par le
contexte que j'évoquais à l'instant
alors ses priorités et la construction
au fond de cette souveraineté européenne
est ce modèle européen nous avons
travaillé toutes ces dernières semaines
avec les différents états membres avec
le président du conseil avec lequel
j'étais il y à quelques instants la
présidente de la commission avec
lesquels j'ai changé lundi évidemment le
président du parlement européen qui
était avec le premier ministre ministres
affaires étrangères il ya quelques
instants comme avec les groupes
parlementaires et j'étais alors côté le
2 décembre dernier à strasbourg pour un
longue échanges pour préparer cette
présidence j'exposerai l'ensemble de ses
priorités devant le parlement européen
le 19 janvier à strasbourg au fond le
mois de janvier sera marquée par une
série d' échanges avec le président du
conseil avec la commission et l'ensemble
du collège des commissaires européens en
france donc début janvier puis un
échange comme il se doit avec le
parlement européen le 19 janvier à
strasbourg
le premier axe de cette présidence c'est
cette europe plus souveraine
l'europe souveraine c'est d'abord c'est
pour moi le premier aspect une europe
capable de maîtriser ses frontières ces
dernières semaines où l'ont encore
montré à travers la crise que nous avons
vécue à la frontière orientera orientale
de l'europe dès la fin de l'été à la
frontière lituanienne et layton puis à
la frontière polonaise
protéger nos frontières est une
condition indispensable à la fois pour
assurer la sécurité des européens pour
relever le défi migratoire et éviter
les drames que nous avons vécu les
situations de fortes tensions que nous
avons vécu les guerres hybride auxquels
nous sommes aujourd'hui confrontés à la
frontière avec la biélorussie mais
également les drames humains ensuite qui
en sont les conséquences directes à
traverser ces trafics qui sont
organisées comme ce que nous avons vécu
dans la manche il y a quelques semaines
travers le drame que nous connaissons
tous et pour éviter que le droit d'asile
qui a été inventé sur le continent
européen et qui est notre honneur ne
puisse être dévoyé nous devons
absolument retrouver une europe qui
sache protéger ses frontières les
retrouve sur la question migratoire une
organisation politique qui me met en
situation de défendre ses valeurs c'est
pourquoi nous nous initierons sous cette
présidence une réforme de l'espace
schengen autour de deux priorités
la première ce sera la mise en place
d'un pilotage politique de schengen
comme nous l'avons fait pour
la zone euro nous avons mis en place une
organisation politique de celle ci avec
des réunions régulières au niveau des
ministres des finances
nous souhaitons installer une
organisation et un pilotage politique de
cet espace schengen à travers des
réunions régulières des ministres en
charge de ces questions
c'est en effet de la crédibilité
européenne et en particulier de celles
et ceux qui se sont engagés dans cette
coopération renforcée que schengen de
pouvoir avoir des réunions régulières de
prendre des décisions politiques de
pouvoir renforcer les contrôles aux
frontières et d'avoir une politique
cohérente de maîtrise
de nos frontières extérieures c'est la
condition préalable à la libre
circulation au sein de schengen ceci
vient s'appuyer sur une réforme que nous
sommes en train de parachever par le
dialogue et les travaux avec la
commission européenne et qui donnera
lieu
à des textes permettant d'améliorer le
fonctionnement interne de cet espace
deuxièmement
souhaitons porter la création d'un
mécanisme de soutien d'urgence aux
frontières en cas de crise quand un état
membre doit soudainement faire face à
une crise qui exigent de renforcer le
contrôle aux frontières extérieures de
notre union comme nous l'avons vécu
quand une fois récemment il doit pouvoir
compter sur l'appui de frontex agence
commune dont c'est la vocation mais
également le renfort solidaire des états
membres en policiers gendarmes comme en
matériel là encore nous avons eu
l'occasion de le faire il y a plusieurs
semaines
lorsque
justement certains de nos partenaires
ont appelé au secours mais les réactions
sont souvent trop tardive les mécanismes
se mettent en place je dirais à chaque
fois de manière spécifique il nous faut
créer véritablement ce mécanisme de
soutien intergouvernementale
troisièmement sur ce sujet de la
protection de nos frontières nous
souhaitons également sous présidence
française faire enfin avancer ce qu'on
appelle le paquet migratoire européen
c'est-à-dire la meilleure aussi
organisation de notre europe en termes
de gestion des migrations avec une
volonté qui est toujours la même
travailler avec les pays d'origine et
les pays de transit pour lutter contre
les trafics éviter ces flux protéger nos
frontières extérieures
harmoniser nos règles en particulier en
matière d'asile ou d'accompagnement des
réfugiés ou des migrants qui sont sur
notre sol et
harmonisation aussi d'une gestion de ce
qu'on appelle les flux secondaire c'est
à dire de la circulation des femmes et
des hommes qui une fois arrivé sur le
sol européen
doivent être beaucoup mieux à la fois
suivis accompagnés mais avec des
procédures plus simples harmonisée au
niveau européen pour éviter des jeux non
coopératifs entre les états membres que
nous voyons depuis plusieurs années
ce texte est aujourd'hui essentiel et
nous souhaitons pouvoir dans le semestre
prochain le faire avancer au delà de la
protection des frontières extérieures
que j'évoquais à l'instant
le deuxième élément clé d'une europe
plus souveraine c'était évidemment
d'avancé sur notre politique de défense
vous le savez là aussi depuis 2010 est
nous avons beaucoup porter l'ambition
d'une défense européenne
avec des avancées considérables
un fonds européen de défense
l'initiative européenne d'intervention
des coopérations là encore une fois
structuré et plusieurs programme commun
franco-allemand ensuite ouvert à
d'autres états membres en matière
d'armement
qu'il s'agisse de l'armement qui sont
dédiés à notre armée de l'air où notre
armée de terre
sur le fondement des initiatives prises
depuis quatre ans il nous faut
aujourd'hui entré dans une phase plus
opérationnelle définir pour nous
européens nos intérêts communs et une
stratégie partagée dans un monde de
menaces et de risques cette présidence
sera à cet égard un moment de définition
de ce que nous avons appelé la boussole
stratégiques c'est-à-dire un livre blanc
européen de défense et de sécurité
qui à la fois présentera l'état des
menaces et fixera nos choix collectifs
nos orientations nos ambitions cette
boussole stratégique a été lancée sous
présidence allemande est elle aboutira
manière concrète sous présidence
française lors du conseil européen du
mois de mars nous aurons d'ailleurs des
discussions lors du conseil de décembre
puis lors du sommet que nous souhaitons
en france au mois de mars sur ce sujet
quelle est la vocation de cette de cette
stratégie d'abord de définir
véritablement
une souveraineté
stratégiques européennes ce concept qui
paraissait impensable là encore une fois
il ya quatre ans permet d'ancrer que
nous européens
que nous soyons d'ailleurs membres de
l'otan ou pas puisque je rappelle que
plusieurs états membres de l'union
européenne ne sont pas membres de l'otan
mais pour tous ceux qui sont membres de
l'otan il réaffirmé leur adhésion à
cette organisation qui a montré son
utilité et son efficacité mais nous
avons des menaces communes et des
objectifs communs et donc nous allons
ainsi définir et porter ensemble une
analyse commune de ces menaces portées
des ambitions nouvelles en matière
d'industrie de défense acte est aussi
d'exercices conjoints de définir nos
partenariat conjoint et au fond de
définir également pour les européens
notre organisation commune sur les
nouveaux espaces de conflits qualité que
sont l'espace maritime
le spatial et le cyber
le conseil européen du mois de mars
permettra d' acte et cette mousse hall
qui a fait l'objet d'un très gros
travail de la part des différents états
membres de la commission et du rop du
haut représentant et de préparer ainsi
des position commune en vue du sommet de
juin à madrid de l'otan elle permettra
aussi de manière très concrète de lancer
pour la première fois des exercices
communs et un renforcement de
l'industrie de défense européen le
troisième axe de cette europe souveraine
c'est la stabilité et la prospérité de
notre voisinage il n'y a pas d'europe
souveraine si nous ne décidons pas en
européens d'avoir notre propre stratégie
notre propre agenda pour ce qui est
notre voisinage sans être exhaustif je
veux ici ici citer deux espaces
géographiques qui donneront lieu à des
initiatives sous présidence française
structurantes depuis le début de mon
mandat j'ai fait de la relation avec
l'afrique une priorité et je crois en
effet profondément que le lien entre nos
deux continents qui bordent les deux
rives de la méditerranée et le grand
projet poli politique et géopolitique
des décennies à venir la relation entre
l'afrique et l'europe sera structurantes
à tous égards
pour la paix autour de la méditerranée
mais aussi pour la paix la prospérité et
de l'europe et de l'afrique
c'est notre intérêt commun
la france a lancé plusieurs initiatives
à cet égard nous avons essayé de bâtir
depuis quatre ans
forme d'aggiornamento de notre politique
africaine et de notre stratégie
mais nous devons le faire en europe et
un en bâtissant un avenir à la jeunesse
africaine pour réduire les inégalités
lutter contre les trafics qui exploitent
la misère et les passeurs qui ont fait
de la méditerranée un cimetière mont
theux et donc
nous organiserons à cet égard en lien
très étroit avec
le président michel la présidente
fondèrent la hyène et l'ensemble des
états membres un sommet entre l'union
africaine et l'union européenne au mois
de février qui se tiendra à bruxelles et
qui réunira les dirigeants des pays et
des institutions de l'union africaine et
de l'union européenne
l'objectif de ce sommet est de refonder
en profondeur la relation parce qu'elle
s'était elle-même il faut bien le dire à
travers ces instruments
bureaucratisé est un peu fatiguée elle
doit s'appuyer sur plusieurs axes que
nous avons préparé ces derniers mois
d'abord refonder un new deal économique
et financier avec l'afrique c'est ce que
nous avons préparé lors du sommet du 18
mai dernier qui s'est tenue si vous en
souvenez à paris sur le financement des
économies africaines c'est celui qui
nous avait permet de déclencher la réole
up la réallocation des droits de tirage
spéciaux du fonds monétaire
international vers les pays africains et
qui nous a permis d'acter ce mécanisme
lors du dernier g20 à rome nous devons
nous européens
aller au bout de cette solidarité à
l'égard des africains qui consiste
simplement à regarder les chiffres qui
sont donnés par la banque mondiale et le
fmi et le fait qu entre 2020 et 2025
il y à 300 milliards d'euros de besoins
de financement pour les économies
africaines car ils ont les conséquences
économiques et financières de lakovic 19
à gérer et une véritable explosion
démographique a embrassé et donc à cet
égard l'europe doit dans les instances
internationales porter une stratégie
commune avec l'afrique pour permettre
cette solidarité
et elle même réactualisé ses mécanismes
d'investissement solidaire à l'égard du
continent africain ensuite c'est de
déployer un agenda en matière
d'éducation de santé et de climat à la
hauteur des enjeux de l'afrique sur ses
trois grands axes le continent africain
à des défis qui sont encore plus
importants que les nôtres sur
l'éducation nous avons relancé en lien
avec le président macky sall il ya
maintenant près de quatre ans
un partenariat commun dans le cadre
justement du partenariat mondial pour
les deux questions nous allons le
poursuivre l' european ise avec un vrai
projet de développer plus avant
l'éducation des jeunes filles partout en
afrique mais également la formation des
enseignants comme le développement des
structures d'éducation sur la santé nous
l'europe a été pionnière en proposant au
g20 le mécanisme dit acta et en ayant
cette solidarité à travers kovacs mais
aussi le transfert de technologie et la
production vers l'afrique c'est ce que
nous allons développer sous présidence
justement française en ayant un
véritable agenda
sanitaire qui consiste à déployer
beaucoup plus vite et beaucoup plus fort
des structures de production de vaccins
et de production justement de systèmes
de santé primaires et puis sur le climat
nous devons accompagner dans sa
transition énergétique et climatique le
continent africain nous ne pouvons pas
laisser les états africains sans
solution lors défis sont eux encore plus
importante les nôtres nous avons
commencé à structurer cet agenda commun
à travers des grandes initiatives
lancées en début d'année comme la grande
muraille verte qui permet de répondre à
la fois aux débuts au défi de la
biodiversité et du climat en afrique
mais là aussi à travers des financements
d'infrastructures et de solutions
énergétiques
nous allons structurer une initiative
forte dans le cadre de ce sommet
troisième grands axes de cette
coopération c'est la sécurité en effet
la france comme vous le savez est
particulièrement impliquée mais nous
souhaitons européaniser c'est ce que
nous faisons dans le cadre justement de
nos actions au sahel
mais européaniser ce partenariat et
avoir véritablement un partenariat de
sécurité entre l'afrique et l'europe ce
qui est la demande des chefs d'état et
de gouvernement pour faire face à la
montée du terrorisme sur leur continent
et puis quatrième point d'avoir un
agenda sur les modalités choisies la
lutte contre les passeurs la lutte
contre justement ce système de misère
qui s'est mise en place et exploiter les
situations plus difficiles et plus
difficile et permettre aussi d'organiser
l'émigration choisie qu'elles soient
scientifiques culturelles académique au
sein du continent africain et entre
l'afrique et l'europe voilà les grands
axes qui seront qui structureront ce
sommet de refondation du 17 et 18
février prochains
c'est un véritable contrat de paix de
prospérité que nous souhaitons mettre en
place pour bâtir des investissements
dans les économies africaines est
justement construire cette cet avenir
commun cet agenda nous l'avons construit
avec les africains au travers de
réunions successives que j'ai pu tenir
ici à paris que le président charles
michel aussi à multiplier encore ces
derniers jours qu avec les ministres
nous avons construite au mois de mai
autour justement de ce sommet de paris
lors du forum de paris pour la paix et
que nous poursuivrons dans les prochaine
semaines notre voisinage immédiat enfin
ce sont aussi les balkans occidentaux
nous organiserons au mois de juin une
conférence sur les balkans occidentaux
parce que plus qu'un voisinage les
balkans sont au coeur de l'europe et il
suffit de regarder une carte il suffit
de regarder notre histoire cette région
est aujourd'hui traversé par des
nouvelles tensions
l'histoire y est de retour le tragique
parfois aussi et donc nous avons une
responsabilité aujourd'hui toute
particulière à l'égard des balkans
occidentaux
il menait une politique de réengagement
mais également d'investissements pour
favoriser l'intégration économique de
cette région pour y développer les
échanges humains pour évoquer la
question des minorités qui parcourt
toute cette région et pour lutter aussi
contre les interférences
contre les manipulations qui sont le
fait de puissants de plusieurs
puissances régionales qui cherche à
travers les balkans à déstabiliser
l'europe je crois que ce travail qui est
un travail politique et économique à
l'égard des balkans occidentaux est un
véritable agenda de souveraineté pour
notre europe car on ne pourra pas bâtir
l'europe de paix des 50 prochaines
années si nous laissons les balkans
occidentaux dans la situation où ils
sont aujourd'hui et c'est donc clarifier
leurs perspectives européennes
réinvestir dans cette région et son
unité et
avoir véritablement une une ambition
commune pour les décennies à venir voilà
les trois grands axes à mes yeux de ce
qu'est une europe plus souveraine sur
laquelle comme vous le voyez le prochain
semestre donnera lieu à des rendez vous
extrêmement important qui viennent
parfois parachever une ambition que nous
poussons depuis plusieurs années mais
qui vont aussi marqué des réponses très
pratique pour nos concitoyens d'un plus
grand contrôle d'une plus grande
maîtrise le deuxième grand axe de cette
présidence française de l'union
européenne
qui je crois d'ailleurs et c'est
dessiner progressivement
pour notre pays comme pour notre
continent durant ces derniers mois et
durant cette cette pandémie que nous
avons tous vécu consiste à bâtir un
nouveau modèle européen de croissance au
fond il nous faut définir ensemble ce
que sera l'europe de 2030
et cette présidence française doit être
l'occasion d'imaginer un nouveau modèle
européen quitte un modèle de production
mais également de solidarité de
régulation en effet
notre europe doit être une europe on
puisse produire créer de la richesse de
la richesse est à la pointe de
l'innovation une europe aussi qui doit
défendre son modèle social parce que
nous n'avons pas les mêmes choix
collectifs que l'asie ou les états unis
d'amérique et une europe qui doit être
au coeur de l'agenda climatique qui est
aussi qui correspond à nos valeurs à cet
égard et je dirais pour bâtir cette
stratégie décennale nous organiserons le
10 et 11 mars en france un sommet
exceptionnel les 27 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement autour de ce sujet majeur
qui est au fond de définir le nouveau
modèle de croissance européen nous
aurons l'occasion d'en détailler les
contours plus précis mais il repose
à meyzieu autour de quatre piliers que
je veux simplement ici esquissé premier
pilier c'est évidemment la capacité à
produire
avoir une réponse économique adapté à la
sortie de crise avec une priorité
faire de l'europe un grand continent de
production d'innovation de création
d'emplois et nous devons partout en
europe avoir une obsession créer des
emplois et lutter contre le chômage et
le chômage de masse tout
particulièrement
cet agenda est indispensable en sortie
de crise parce que nous avons et nous
aurons à vivre les conséquences
économiques et sociales de cette
pandémie pour cela nous avons à bâtir ce
que nous avons commencé à préparer mais
ce sommet de mars permettra d'en
parachever le travail et la cohérence la
construction de filières industrielles
fortes et intégrée l'hydrogène les
batteries l'espace les semi conducteurs
le cloud la défense la santé la culture
et les industries culturelles et
créatives
dans tous ces domaines à haute intensité
technologique de création de valeur ou
d'emplois qui vont structurer
le monde de 2030 qui vont structurer la
création d'emploi la création de valeur
ajoutée ou la capacité à avoir de
l'influencé sur le monde de demain nous
devons garantir le positionnement de
l'europe notre capacité à avoir
évidemment des champions notre capacité
à créer le maximum d'emplois sur notre
sol et notre capacité à définir les
standards de demain et avoir donc notre
indépendance
pour cela l'action au niveau d'un état
n'est pas la bonne échelle vous m'avez
plusieurs fois entendu dire cela mais
quand nous avons amené la compétition
par rapport aux chinois aux états unis
d'amérique quand parfois nous avons pris
du retard ce qui est le cas de certains
de ses grands sujets je pense au cloud
aux semi conducteurs par exemple où
l'europe de fait à d'ores et déjà des
dépendance technologique
si nous voulons le rattraper et parfois
prendre de l'avancé nous devons agir en
européens et nous devons penser en
européen nos investissements en matière
de compétences d'implantation
industrielle
d'innovation soit pour réindustrialiser
soit pour bâtir de nouvelles filières
innovantes et pour là aussi construire
de la véritable souveraineté
technologique en europe et donc d'ici le
mois de mars nous parachèveront et la
commission européenne un rôle tout
particulier une série de plans
d'investissement européen et d'alliances
industrielles nouvelles autour de ses
grands objectifs que j'évoquais tout à
l'heure
ce modèle de croissance et
d'investissements supposera aussi des
règles budgétaires et financières
adaptées
permettant de donner la priorité aux
investissements nécessaires pour
accompagner les transitions en
particulier climatique et numérique
nous aurons pour cela besoin de
commencer à bâtir un cadre budgétaire et
financier crédible simplifiée
transparent capable de contribuer à
cette ambition d'une europe plus forte
plus juste et plus durable et
de ce sommet du 10 et 11 mars nous
aurons ainsi une session de réflexion
stratégique que nous organiserons pour
les 27 états membres autour de ce sujet
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que durant la pandémie nous avons
mis entre parenthèses d'application de
nos règles budgétaires communes
nous devons revenir à des règles
budgétaires qui seuls permettent la
convergence entre nos économies surtout
pour celles et ceux qui partagent une
monnaie commune mais nous ne pouvons pas
faire comme si rien ne s'était passé et
pour réussir justement le développement
de ces alliances de ces filières
industrielles fortes et d'innovation il
nous faut acter le besoin
d'investissements nouveaux ces
investissements nouveaux nous devons les
intégrer dans notre cadre budgétaire et
donc il nous faut une discussion
stratégique qui découlent de cela des
dires face à ce défi à la transition
climatique numéri sanitaire culturel
stratégique comment notre europe doit
justement prendre les bons
investissements au bon niveau et
repenser notre cadre budgétaire à cet
égard nous ne réussirons pas cette
transition nous ne les mèneront pas à
l'échelle de notre continent si nous en
revenons à un cadre budgétaire qui a été
créé au début des années 90 en même
temps il nous faudra aussi
relancer un travail commun sur le cadre
financier
car si la banque centrale européenne à
une réaction rapide totalement adapté au
moment de la crise
nous avons aussi à parachever une europe
bancaire et une europe des marchés de
capitaux parce que face à tous ces
investissements il nous faut aussi levé
au maximum de l'argent privé et orienter
ses financements privés vers nos
priorités ceci suppose d'aller plus loin
dans l'intégration d'une europe d'un
vrai marché de capitaux d'une europe
financière enfin intégrer c'est au coeur
de cet agenda et c'est un élément de
cohérence
car nous ne réussirons en effet ces
transformations que si nous savons
réadapter nos règles budgétaires et
financières deuxième pilier de ce
nouveau modèle européen de croissance
c'est de concilier développement
économique et ambitions climatiques et
l'europe a une opportunité c'est de
devenir championne en la matière parce
que c'est un levier de création
d'emplois et de valeur pour aujourd'hui
et pour demain en devenant le premier
continent du monde à adopter l'objectif
de neutralité carbone nous nous sommes
fixé un cadre ambitieux je le rappelle
c'était en décembre de l'année dernière
les 27 se sont engagés les premiers
autour de cet objectif atteindre cet
objectif suppose non pas de produire
moins mais de consommer moins mais
d'innover de transformer nos politiques
de mettre en place est bonne régulation
et les banques d'investissement pour
économiser
l'énergie qu'on peut économiser en
continuant à innover produits pour
électrifier tout ce qui peut l'être et
pour avoir une production d'électricité
la plus décarbonés possible
il nous faut donc inventer les solutions
de décarbonation de notre économie soit
compatible avec cet agenda de croissance
le 14 juillet dernier la commission
européenne a présenté un ensemble de
textes législatifs
traduisant concrètement notre ambition
de neutralité carbone pour 2050 et de
réduction de 55% de nos émissions de gaz
à effet de serre d'ici 2030
le semestre de présidence française doit
faire avancer ses textes avec toujours
un objectif ne pas perdre une minute car
il s'agit d'une urgence absolue avoir le
bon niveau d'investissement et
d'innovation pour permettre de concilier
développement économique ambitions
climatiques et avoir le bon niveau
d'accompagnement des industries et des
ménages pour permettre constamment l'
équilibre entre ambition climatique et
justice sociale et enfin
garder notre compétitivité notre
ambition climatiques en particulier sous
présidence française la de nos objectifs
sera la mise en place du mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
cette fameuse taxe entre guillemets
carbone aux frontières de l'europe qui
permet justement
de conduire cette transition pour
l'ensemble de nos industries en
préservant notre compétitivité
ça consiste en quoi eh bien à corriger
le fait que nous allons demander des
efforts d investissement les accompagner
décarbonés notre industrie mais que nous
continuerons à importer parfois des
biens qui viennent de régions qui ne
font toujours pas le même effort et bien
que nous compenserons à nos frontières
le différentiel ce en quoi nos
industriels à juste titre ne dirai que
nous créons en quelque sorte un billet
de compétitivité et que nous allons
simplement supprimer notre industrie à
défaut de la moderniser
concilier compétitivité ambitions
industrielles avec l'ambition climatique
c'est mettre en place ce mécanisme qui
est clé est que nous souhaitons
parachever sous présidence française
ensuite nous souhaitons avancer sur la
mise en cohérence de notre politique
commerciale et de notre politique
climatique et de biodiversité
ainsi la présidence française sera un
moment clé pour pousser ce qu'on appelle
les clauses miroir et avoir des
exigences environnementales et sociales
dans nos accords commerciaux c'était
aussi une question d'équité
les acteurs économiques européens ne
peuvent pas être les victimes de leurs
efforts pour la planète et donc ces
clauses miroir c'est une mise en
cohérence de notre agenda commercial
avec notre agenda climatique il nous
allons d'ailleurs tout faire ça ne se
fera pas à l'échelle de la présidence
française de l'union européenne pour que
dans le cadre de la réforme de
l'organisation mondiale du commerce nous
puissions intégrer cet agenda
environnementale et sociale
enfin sur sur ce volet nous ferons aussi
avancer les négociations sur la mise en
place d'un instrument européen
de lutte contre la déforestation
importés qui visera à interdire
l'importation dans l'union européenne de
soja boeuf huile de palme bois cacao
café quand ils contribuent à la
déforestation
en effet il nous faut re synchronisée
notre agenda de lutte contre le
dérèglement climatique et notre agenda
de préservation de la biodiversité les
deux sont liés
nous l'avons montré en début d'année en
organisant ici même le one planet solide
pour la biodiversité qui a permis de
relancer cet agenda donc durant l'année
2021 et la france a porté la première un
agenda de lutte contre la déforestation
importés qui est très cohérent avec là
aussi notre politique climatique et
notre politique agricole
lorsque nous nous battons pour un plan
protéines nous luttons contre la
déforestation importés par des
substances protéinique qui viennent de
zones qui produisent ces protéines
végétales grâce à de la déforestation et
donc vous voyez la cohérence et l'esprit
de système de cet agenda mais nous
devons le porter au niveau européen pour
être collectivement efficace et ainsi
défendre au niveau européen l'excellence
de notre modèle agricole qui est un
modèle de haute qualité que nous
souhaitons continuer d'accompagner dans
sa transformation et là aussi dans la
préservation de la biodiversité
troisième élément de ce nouveau modèle
européen de croissance
c'est de faire de l'europe une puissance
du numérique
le numérique est en train de transformer
évidemment tous nos secteurs de
production est au coeur des innovations
mondiales et réussir à créer de la
croissance des nouveaux emplois dans
notre continent réussir aussi à défendre
nos valeurs nos principes c'est réussir
à créer une europe du numérique en tout
cas à la parachever
d'abord c'est réussir à continuer de
faire émerger des acteurs de plus en
plus fort des champions du numérique en
soutenant l'innovation et la croissance
des acteurs émergent dans ce domaine
la france mène un peu plus de quatre ans
une stratégie en la matière qui a montré
son efficacité
à travers les résultats que nous avons
sur l'europe continentale en termes de
levée de fonds de création de start up
et de lever aujourd'hui des tickets les
plus importants nous souhaitons
européaniser cette stratégie et réussir
à avoir justement des fonds européens de
financement de nos startups et de deux
acteurs du numérique les plus innovants
en mobilisant nos investisseurs
institutionnels c'est ce qu'on appelle
les fameux fonds tibi que nous avons
développée au niveau français que nous
souhaitons développer au niveau européen
et qu'il s'agisse des domaines les plus
technologiques à la santé numérique ou
d'autres cela nous permet de là aussi
aller plus vite et plus fort dans le
développement nos acteurs numériques
mais permettre aussi de défendre leur
souveraineté et d'éviter que ces
derniers lorsqu'ils sont en phase de
croissance les plus fortes n'aille
chercher cet argent chez les anglo
saxons ou les asiatiques
les dix premières capitalisons les dix
premières capitalisations mondiales
aujourd'hui
voix huit entreprises de la tech et
aucune européenne c'est ça la réalité
aujourd'hui du capitalisme mondial et
donc
ce qui est une source d'espoir c'est que
parmi tout particulièrement celles huit
entreprises de la tech qui appartiennent
aux des capitalisations mondiales aucune
n'existait il ya 25 ans donc tous les
espoirs sont permis simplement il nous
faut regarder les règles de cette
compétition internationale pour y
arriver elles sont simples si on veut
arriver créer un vrai marché intégré du
numérique simplifier nos règles
supprimer les barrières entre les
vingt-sept et donc continuer à
travailler sur ce marché unique du
numérique à voir les talents et donc
continuer dans notre capacité en
européen à bâtir un agenda
d'attractivité des talents on a commencé
à le faire en franco français il nous
faut avoir cet agenda au niveau européen
troisièmement attirer les financements
c'est ce que j'évoquais à l'instant et
c'est le lien d'ailleurs avec une union
des marchés de capitaux c'est réussir à
mobiliser l'épargné institutionnelle des
européens vers l'innovation le risque le
développement de ces champions c'est un
élément essentiel pour bâtir le nouveau
modèle de croissance européen
le deuxième axe sur le numérique c'est
de ne pas subir la loi des autres
puissances en définissant nous mêmes les
règles pour le monde numérique j'ai
évoqué encore il ya quelques semaines au
forum de paris pour la paix nous avons
déjà réussi en européen a porté une
réglementation européenne pour la
protection des données individuelles
non seulement c'est un succès sur le
continent européen nous avons amélioré
la protection de nos citoyens et de
leurs données mais nous en avons fait un
standard international
les grands groupes américains se sont
mis à ce standard ce qui montre que
quand nous savons nous organiser nous
créons des standards à l'échelle de la
planète
il nous faut poursuivre ce travail nous
avons obtenu un accord international sur
la taxation des multinationales et en
particulier les géants du numérique
l'agenda
sous la présidence française permettra
de mettre en oeuvre cet accord qui a été
finalisé en g20 au niveau européen d'ici
au printemps nous aurons passé dans les
conseil compétent particulier du conseil
ecofin les textes permettant justement
de mettre en place ces deux piliers et
donc de parachever ce travail pour une
vraie taxation des multinationales
ensuite il y a deux textes pionniers qui
seront discutés avec le parlement
européen et sur lequel nous
concentrerons la présidence française le
premier c'est l'acte pour le marché
numérique ou dma qui vise à éviter que
les
pour le marché numérique c'est au fond
un acte de régulation économique
de ce secteur
le deuxième c'est l'acte pour les
services numériques d'idées est ça qui
établira un régime de responsabilité des
grandes plateformes au titre des
produits qu'elles vendent et surtout des
contenus qu'elle diffuse et ça c'est une
régulation inédite européenne pour
lutter contre la haine en ligne pour
définir la responsabilité de ces grandes
plateformes sur leur contenu ce qui fait
de l'europe un continent pionnier en la
matière
chaque jour nous avons évoqué des sujets
qu'il s'agisse d'antisémitisme de
racisme de discours de haine de
harcèlement en ligne il n'ya aujourd'hui
à proprement parler pas de régulation
internationale sur ces sujets ce texte
sera fondateur en ce qu'il permet à
l'échelle d'un continent de mettre en
place pour la première fois une
régulation des contenus et une
responsabilité des plateformes ces deux
textes
dma et ds à seront des priorités sur ce
volet numérique de cette présidence
française
enfin et c'est le quatrième pilier de ce
modèle européen de croissance que nous
voulons mettre au coeur de cette
présidence ce qui doit distinguer le
modèle de production européen des autres
c'est notre capacité collective à
proposer aux travailleurs des emplois de
qualité qualifiés et mieux rémunéré
c'est au fond de dire comme d'ailleurs
le le rapport blanchard tyrol et
l'ensemble des économistes qui nous ont
remis il ya quelques mois le temps ce
rapport sur le nouveau modèle de
croissance que nous voulons défendre
donc parfaitement dit c'est de créer les
bons emplois
l'europe s'est toujours construite sur
ces deux piliers la compétitivité la
capacité à produire et innover mais
aussi sa capacité à avoir des
préférences collectives et des
équilibres sociaux et permet penser les
équilibres de nos sociétés la justice de
celle ci et donc la capacité à créer des
bons emplois des emplois de mieux en
mieux payés à former ses salariés
si notre europe ne protège pas et ne
protège pas mieux les plus faibles si
elle laisse prospérer le dumping social
alors apparaît un marché sans règles ou
ne se retrouve plus les classes moyennes
et les classes populaires
c'est cette europe là qui a nourri le
break site ne nous y trompons pas
lorsqu'une partie de nos peuples
considère qu'ils sont les perdants d'un
système ils finissent par le rejeter
légitimement nous avons d'ores et déjà
obtenus ces dernières années des
résultats importants qu'on pensait
inaccessible je le rappelle il ya
quelques années sur le travail des
tâches et le changement de ces règles
l'accroissement de ses contrôles
j'étais encore hier d'ailleurs sur
un des plus grands chantiers de travaux
publics que nous avons sur notre sol
dans l'allier mais j'ai pu regarder la
mise en oeuvre des contrôles que nous
pouvons et dictée de manière très
concrète grâce à cette réforme
européenne que nous avons initié mais
cette présidence doit être l'opportunité
d'aller plus loin et c'est pour cela que
j'ai tenu à associer les partenaires
sociaux à la préparation de cette
présidence et nous l'avons fait il ya
plusieurs mois en marge du sommet sous
présidence portugaise à travers une
série d' échanges bilatéraux nous allons
avancer durant ce semestre à venir sur
plusieurs sujets d'abord la directive
sur les salaires minimums dans l'union
européenne qui définit non pas un smic
européen comme une moyenne mais tire
tous les bas salaires vers le haut grâce
à un salaire minimum décent sera au
coeur de notre présidence les bonnes
discussions de la semaine dernière dans
le cadre du conseil
des ministres compétents a permis une
avancée considérable et nous pourrons je
le crois parachever cette avancée pour
véritablement créer un système beaucoup
plus efficace à l'envers tirant vers un
salaire minimum décent en europe et dans
tous les pays nous agirons aussi pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
avec la directive sur la transparence
salariale qui vise à mettre fin aux
écarts de salaires entre les femmes et
les hommes nous souhaitons également
les prochaines heures seront
déterminantes en la matière pouvoir
finaliser les textes européens pour les
quotas dans le cadre des conseils
d'administration c'était que c'était
bloqué depuis plusieurs années je pense
que nous pourrons finaliser ces textes
lors du prochain semestre et nous
traitons également faire avancer le
devoir de vigilance à l'échelle
européenne
voilà nos priorités sur ce deuxième
pilier que le modèle européen de
croissance qui en quelque sorte et notre
capacité collective à réinventer ce qui
nous a fait à l'aune du 21e siècle
savoir innover savoir produire savoir
reconstruire notre souveraineté
technologique et la justice sociale à
l'échelle du continent nous aurons aussi
apporter beaucoup d'autres sujets
majeurs sur l'union de la santé publique
sur les sujets de manipulation de
l'information d'agriculture
d'interdiction des personnes des
pesticides sur les ruches des régions
ultra périphériques
sur le capitalisme responsable et tant
d'autres sur la compagnie me
l'accompagnement d'un modèle agricole
d'excellence mais le fil rouge et la
faire en sorte que cette présidence soit
utile qu'elle permette à l'europe de
s'affirmer en tant que puissance et
reprendre le contrôle de son destin et
d'affirmer la singularité de son modèle
enfin le troisième grand axe que je veux
ici présentés et qui sera au coeur de
cette de cette présidence c'est ce que
j'appellerais une europe humaine
à taille humaine à l'échelle humaine
pour citer les grands auteurs et je
crois que cela contribue de cette
singularité qui est la nôtre
nous avons sur ce ce petit morceau de
terre qui nous a été donnée fait naître
la démocratie la renaissance l'humanisme
l'esprit des lumières les droits de
l'homme
avec toujours une vocation profonde qui
fait l'europe et qui doit continuer de
la faire une certaine idée de l'homme
et voilà pourquoi au delà des priorités
que je viens de présenter je veux que
nous puissions faire de cette présidence
française un grand moment d'humanisme
européen un temps de mobilisation pour
ce que j'appelle cette europe humaine
avec plusieurs initiatives
là aussi qui scanderont les prochains
mois d'abord au mois de mai nous aurons
un conclure la conférence sur l'avenir
de l'europe celle ci c'est une
proposition que j'avais pu faire au
printemps 2010 9 elle a donné lieu à un
immense travail et je veux vraiment
remercier partout à travers l'europe
l'ensemble des équipes d associations d
engager des jeunes en particulier qui se
sont investis dans ce ce travail et qui
va permettre de déboucher sur des
conclusions que au mois de mai nous
aurons à discuter avec les institutions
de notre europe avec les gouvernements
la société civile
cette étape très importante d'abord
parce qu'elle est le fruit d'un travail
collectif d'une mobilisation mais parce
qu'elle est le début aussi de cet élan
refondateurs nous ne devons pas chercher
au mois de mai à avoir des conclusions
ficelé mais plutôt à essayer de rebâtir
un élan fondateur où nous devons
repenser cette vocation humaniste de
l'europe plus efficace plus proche de
nos concitoyens
je crois que c'est essentiel pour
qu'elles soient justement plus humaine
une europe qui se redonne quelques
ambitions simples une europe qui se
donne des règles pour mieux associer nos
concitoyens est résolument plus
démocratique et une europe beaucoup plus
simple ce qui est un agenda que nous ne
devons pas perdre de vue qu'ils étaient
essentielles cet élan peut-être ira
jusqu'à une refondation de notre été et
je me félicite d'ailleurs que la
nouvelle coalition en allemagne se soit
dotée d'une telle ambition je
rencontrerai demain pour la première
fois le chancelier allemand sur la seule
ce qui viendra à paris donc demain midi
et nous aurons l'occasion d'en discuter
je pense que cette capacité cette
disponibilité politique de plusieurs
états membres à embrasser ces nouveaux
sujets est essentielle pour que ce
rendez vous du printemps 2019 soit à la
bonne ambitions c'est à dire celle de
l'histoire et des prochaines décennies
nous porterons aussi comme nous l'avons
toujours fait la question des valeurs
qui sont le fondement même la raison
même de notre union nous connaissons les
débats actuels sur l'état de droit la
présidence française aura à les mener
pour en revenir dans les questions sur
le détail des procédures de tous ces
sujets mais je veux ici dire que d'abord
ces questions ne sont pas négociables
elles sont existentielle elles sont à la
base de notre été elles sont au coeur de
ce qui est la convention même des droits
de l'homme qui a précédé à notre union
elles sont dans les textes
constitutionnels de notre union mais ces
questions ne doivent pas opposer l'est
et l'ouest de notre continent elle ne
confronte pas des pays des sociétés ou
des peuples d'europe entre non
ils sont un combat politique
existentielle pour nos valeurs et pour
notre union il y à des forces politiques
qui remettent en cause ce qui est ce
socle de valeurs de droit qui a fait
notre europe et donc nous devons aussi
réfléchir à des nouveaux outils pas
seulement de sanctions mais également
d'encouragement d'accompagnement il ya
un travail politique profond car nous
devons aussi regarder des pays qui sont
en train de douter de la réalité ou de
l'efficacité ou de la pertinence de ses
valeurs c'est notre responsabilité
d'européens de le faire c'est pourquoi
entre autres je souhaite que durant ce
semestre nous puissions trouver des
nouveaux instruments pour aider à faire
vivre nos libertés démocratiques et
qu'en particulier le plus vont nous
puissions mettre sur pied un fonds de
soutien européen au journalisme
indépendant et d'investigation
ne mèneront ce combat pour la défense de
l'état de droit comme nous mais non le
combat pour nos valeurs celles de
l'égalité de la lutte contre toutes les
haines et toutes les discriminations
en visant à étendre la liste des
infractions européenne au crime les
discours de haine en nous dotant d'une
stratégie de lutte contre le racisme et
l'antisémitisme en dotant l'union d'une
législation sur la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
enfin l'europe c'est une histoire une
culture à nul autre pareil qu'il nous
incombe de porter de défendre et de
transmettre et cette europe humaine que
j'ai évoqué cet humanisme européen cette
appartenance que nous avons mis aussi au
coeur justement de cette devise
n'existe que s'il est charnelle sensible
c'est notre culture de repères notre
histoire ce qui passe par également
notre éducation
l'espoir européenne n'est pas seulement
l'addition de 27 histoire nationale elle
a une cohérence une unité que chacun
pressent mais qui ne se donne pas avoir
encore pleinement c'est pourquoi je
souhaite que nous puissions relancer
sous cette présidence française un grand
travail sur l'histoire de l'europe mais
un grand travail qui doit se faire dans
un cadre
historiographique indépendant nous
vivons un moment politique en europe où
le révisionnisme s'installe dans
plusieurs pays où le révisionnisme
historique est utilisé par des
puissances qui veulent remettre en cause
nos valeurs notre histoire parfois
revoir leur propre rôle durant notre
vingtième siècle nous devons absolument
bâtir un cadre académique où les
historiens de toute l'europe pourront
continuer à oeuvrer sur un travail
historique indépendant reposant sur les
traces l'épreuve les controverses et je
souhaite que nous puissions au mois de
juin prochain en france
initié ce travail qui donnera lieu à une
préparation ardue et scientifique par un
comité indépendant durant les prochains
mois mais de forger une histoire et une
historiographie
de notre europe et d'une histoire
mondiale de l'europe c'est indispensable
et sur la base de ce travail nous
devrons d'ailleurs considéré
comment ce travail pourra ensuite être
décliné dans chaque pays européen
l'esprit européen n'est pas seulement à
passer une flamme qu'il faut animer
rallumer chaque jour ans de manière
sensible dans nos écoles dans nos musées
dans notre culture
c'est pourquoi nous organiserons aussi
en juin prochain une grande réunion des
universités européennes
en effet lors du discours de la sorbonne
j'avais proposé que nous puissions créer
des universités européennes
nous avons été nos universités ont été
extraordinairement efficace 40
universités européennes existent
aujourd'hui cela fait partie de ces
réalisations très concrète qui depuis le
discours de la sorbonne font que celui
ci est devenu une réalité nous réunirons
ses 40 universités plus toutes celles
qui se seront créés et peut-être dans
l'entre-temps en france afin de pouvoir
continuer cet agenda mais de consacrer
aussi l'importance des universités en
europe je souhaite aussi que cette
présidence soit l'occasion de créer une
académie d'europe qui réunira des
intellectuels de toutes disciplines des
27 états membres pour éclairer nos
débats éthiques nos rapports aux
libertés proposer aussi des actions et
des projets culturels
et puis pour que chacun puisse avoir
accès aux grandes oeuvres artistiques
qui nous font européen qui nous font
vibrer comme européen nous prendrons
plusieurs initiatives culturelles fortes
durant cette présidence d'abord d'ores
et déjà
tout ce que la france porte de culture
dans notre pays hexagone et outre mer
mais aussi dans nos représentations nos
sites culturels partout en europe et à
l'international s'est mis aux couleurs
réelles ambitions de cette présidence
française nous le ferons dans un temps
un peu particulier où nous aurons aussi
au mois de mai prochain célébrer les 30
ans d'arreter et d'une fierté culturelle
d'un grand projet européen mais nous
développerons plusieurs initiatives en
lien avec tous les partenaires qui
souhaitent nous accompagner en la
matière en déployant des micros folie
ou
nous aurons à travers tous les pays
toutes les régions toutes les villes
européennes qui souhaitent justement
s'associer à ce que nous avons pu mener
en france des initiatives pour
développer l'accès à des opéras des
musées des oeuvres d'art notre
sensibilité commune à travers des
organisations virtuelles mais qui
permettent dans telle ou telle commune
tel ou tel endroit où il n'y a pas accès
à des
établissements de culture d'avoir accès
à ses oeuvres nous l'avons développée en
france ces dernières années avec un
succès véritable nous le ferons au
niveau européen avec là aussi un point
de rendez-vous au mois de mai prochain
2022 sera là mais européenne de la
jeunesse j'avais évoqué à la sorbonne
une généralisation du programme
d'échangé erasmus à tous les jeunes
européens car il donne une ouverture
d'esprit qui est un bagage unique dans
la vie adulte nous l'avons déjà élargi
aux apprentis et avons déjà doublé le
nombre de bénéficiaires et je veux
remercier toutes celles et ceux qui se
sont engagés dans ses ambitions dans
cette ambition et au conte permis aux
apprentis partout en europe de
bénéficier de ce nouveau programme
erasmus plus
allons plus loin y réfléchissons à un
service civique européen de six mois
ouvert à tous les jeunes de moins de 25
ans pour un échange universitaire ou
d'apprentissage un stage ou une action
associative
ce service civique européen c'est une
proposition que nous on fait les jeunes
européens et qui ont été remises aux
ministres compétents je souhaite que
nous puissions enclenché la mise en
oeuvre concrète et véritable de cette
initiative qui vient de notre jeunesse
durant ce semestre
cora a présidé la france vous l'avez
compris c'est cette europe plus humaine
c'est celle qui à travers toutes ces
initiatives permet dans nos écoles nos
universités à travers la culture
de défendre nos valeurs mais de faire en
sorte que ce combat pour l'europe ne
soit pas un combat d'entre eux soit
mais le ticket toujours à mener
quand on considère que l'europe est un
acquis on ne se bat plus pour elle
quand on oublie que l'europe est ce qui
nous a fait ce qui nous force ce qui
nous lie on finit par penser qu'on
pourrait la désagréger sans conséquence
et donc ce combat est aussi
existentielle que celui pour la
souveraineté et pour le modèle de
croissance que j'évoquais voilà le
triptyque autour duquel
nous organiserons ce semestre à venir
avec plusieurs rendez-vous que j'ai pu
égrainer au travers donc de ma
présentation ce sont les principaux mais
il y aura chaque semaine des réunions
ministérielles des réunions informelles
ou formelles mais cet agenda sera ainsi
scandé je ne serai pas plus long je vais
maintenant répondre à toutes les
questions vous pouvez avoir ce que je
vous propose c'est que nous ayons
d'aborder des questions sur l'europe
tous les sujets sur l'europe évidemment
y compris les sujets qu'il n'ait pas pu
aborder pour parler notre présidence
parler ensuite peut-être des sujets
internationaux
je ne m'appesantirai pas sur les
questions de politique intérieure
française ce n'est pas l'objet de cette
conférence mais évidemment s'il y avait
quelques questions plus nationale mais
je ne les hais ce qui devrait pas mais
ça n'est pas le coeur de cette
conférence
monsieur le président
bonjour monsieur président deux petites
questions à la suite cette longue
présentation a l'impression que vous
avez disant devoir vous alors que ça ça
va plutôt se résumer à deux mois et demi
il peut être plus si les français le
veulent bien
la première porte sur le les
investissements que vous souhaitez
intégrer au cadre budgétaire européen
est ce que cela signifie que vous me lis
très clairement pour l'abandon des 3% ou
[Musique]
modification de ceux de ses 3 %
intégrant des exceptions et les quelle
est la deuxième question plus politique
vous allez vous rendre en budapest très
et cendres pour rencontrer un adversaire
politique sur la scène européenne viktor
orban vous aurez besoin de rassembler la
famille politique pour faire avancer
tous vos projets
qu'est ce que vous attendez de cette
rencontre qu'elle quel deal voulez vous
passer avec lui qu'est ce que vous
attendez de lui sachant que lui aussi
est en campagne et n'a pas tellement
intérêt à vous aider
emmanuel berretta le coup bien sûr
première question d'évidence il nous
faut mener une politique
d'investissement sur toutes les filières
que j'évoquais il nous faut aussi mener
une politique d'accompagnement de ses
investissements sur le plan social ce
sont d'abord des financements européens
que nous devons acte est d'ores et déjà
je veux ici vous rappelez nous avons
commencé cette transformation nous
l'avons commencé grâce au travail franco
allemand puis européen
il y a quatre ans quand on disait quant
à la sorbonne je disais notre europe
doit changer ses règles budgétaires
notre europe doit bâtir des financements
commun notre europe doit avoir plus de
solidarité budgétaire ni les belles
idées françaises les allemands diront
toujours non
nous l'avons fait pas des déclarations
nous l'avons fait avec la chancelière
merkel en mai 2020 parce qu'il y avait
la crise oui mais parce que nous avons
su réagir pendant ce temps à la crise
sur cette base là nous avons construit
un accord européen en juillet 2020
d'ores et déjà nous avons ces 750
milliards d'investissements en dur
c'est une vraie transformation du budget
et donc avec tout ça on peut déployer
des investissements qui n'était pas dans
nos budgets parce qu'au fond c'est
presque plus qu'un doublement du budget
traditionnel parce que c'est sûr -
d'année et donc nous sommes en train de
déclencher aujourd'hui ses alliances
industrielles et ses grands
investissements de sortie de crise sur
ces ses nouveaux projets ses nouvelles
priorités est donc le premier point la
réponse est que nous avons déjà
construit commencé à construire un cadre
macroéconomique au niveau européen
solidaires pour faire face à ces
investissements ensuite nous devons
avoir une discussion stratégique pour
dire est-ce que c'est suffisant je veux
pas présenter cette discussion faut
qu'elle soit sincère donc on doit déjà
dire qu'est ce qu'on veut faire si on
dit on veut mieux se protéger qu'est-ce
qu'on veut investir en européen et au
niveau national chacun pour notre
défense pour nos technologies pour notre
climat sur cette base là est ce que
notre paquet de relance européen est
suffisant ou pas et ensuite il nous faut
décider s'il nous faut un plus grand
budget européen si on décide que ces
investissements sont communs ou s'il
nous faut certains investissements
nationaux qui sortent des règles et donc
je pense qu'il faut sortir de nos vieux
tabous et de nos vieux fétiche
la question c'est pas plus pour aux
comptes le 3 % elle est dépassée cette
question il faut des règles budgétaires
pour rester sérieux sinon ya plus de
confiance il faut des règles de
convergence financière oui la question
c'est comment on articule le sérieux
budgétaire et la convergence entre
européens avec une ambition qui est
indispensable pour nous tous ça peut
être par la capacité à lever des
nouveaux financements en européen sur
les marchés comme nous l'avons fait
pendant 750 milliards ça peut être de
dire nous décidons d'avoir un plus gros
budget européen et donc plus de
contributions dans les années à venir
entre européens ça veut pouvoir dire
peut-être que nous décidons que chaque
européen sur tel était le sujet à une
catégorie de dépenses d'investissement
qui sort des règles il ya plusieurs
solutions possibles je ne veux pas ici
les présenter
mais il nous faut aller vers une
politique d'investissement cohérente
avec ses priorités je serai lundi en
effet à budapest pour rencontrer le
premier ministre viktor orban puis pour
avoir une discussion avec le groupe
devise grade viktor orban n'ayant la
présidence de celui-ci
opposant adversaires politiques mais
c'est un partenaire européen autour de
la table je pense que c'est très
important de toujours rappeler cette
grammaire nous sommes 27 chefs d'état et
de gouvernement autour de la table
quelles que soient nos sensibilités
politiques nos choix nous devons
travailler ensemble pour notre europe et
donc mon devoir et je le prends comme
tel depuis le premier jour c'est de
porter la voix de la france de défendre
les intérêts de la france mais d'aider à
construire des compromis utile pour
l'europe et la france autour de la table
viktor orban c'est aussi faire ce
travail et donc il peut y avoir des
désaccords profonds et il n'y en a mais
notre devoir dans les prochains mois
c'est de permettre à l'europe sur
l'agenda que j'ai évoquées de continuer
à avancer il est très clair que sur le
sujet de l'état de droit il y aura des
désaccords jeunes évoqué tout à l'heure
mais je pense que sur les sujets de
souveraineté sur les sujets le modèle de
croissance sur les sujets multiples que
j'ai pu évoquer il peut y avoir aussi
une capacité à trouver des compromis
utile avec les vingt-sept c'est
d'ailleurs la condition pour avancer
c'est ce que nous avons aussi pu faire à
plusieurs reprises
la parole est à virginie malingre du
journal le monde qui est en
visioconférence depuis bruxelles
oui bonjour monsieur le président
je je je voulais voir sur la pologne des
becs en ce moment et des chantres la
commission et l'insomnie qui n'avance
pas
combien temps vous pensez que ça peut
durer cette escale d'état
de zinc résistance pas grand chose ou la
collection attendent parce débouche sur
du pain doit par ce biais comme la
commission parce qu'elle est que l'élite
suez est ce qu on sait que c'est pas
dangereux pour la construction
européenne c'était ma première question
et je voulais aussi sa robe n'est pas
encore candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
peut-être que vous avez une tendance
mais vous aux mélodies si enfin les
chefs des options d'état s'inquiète
comment on peut combiner une présidence
du conseil de l'union européenne et
électorale vous avez bien le dire en
votre discours souriez mais concrètement
qu'est ce que vous demandez comment
comment vous allez réussir à rester
honnête entier en anglais
bon alors je dois dire que d'abord
l'orientation des micros fait que quand
une question qui est posée même dans la
salle celui qui est ici en temps assez
mal je le dis juste pour la technique
mais alors en plus c'est encore plus dur
en visio et j'ai aggravé mon problème en
vous posant une question au milieu de
votre deuxième question donc du coup
j'ai compris et qu'on les gemmois si
votre première question et sur l'état de
droit
et alors est ce que ça couvre la pologne
et la hongrie ou uniquement à la pologne
je n'ai pas compris et votre deuxième
question du coup je n'ai pas entendu le
début parce que j'étais en train de
parler alors je vous ai entendu parler
je suis confuse donc une première
question c'était vraiment sur la pologne
sur les discussions en cours entre la
commission et la sony pour débloquer ou
pas le plan de relance pour débloquer
les fonds du plan de relance européen
je voulais sera comment vous m'entendez
mieux les arts si vous pensez que cet
état gazeux dans lequel on est déjà des
mois maintenant que dire longtemps
et comment peut on sortir et s'il ya
danger pour la construction européenne
de votre point de vue la deuxième
question c'était comment est ce que vous
allez faire pour
cumuler
deux rôles qui paraît être antagonistes
celui de
et
la présence
éventuelle mans candidat à l'élection
présidentielle en france vous n'êtes pas
encore mais que vous serez sûrement
bientôt merci beaucoup alors sur votre
première question vous avez
sur la pologne il y a deux sujets le
premier sujet
ce sont les éléments de conditionnalité
qui sont le fruit de notre accord
signé au plan de relance complété par le
parlement européen qui a fait un
considérable travail sur ce sujet et le
fait que dans les critères pour
bénéficier du justement du plan de
relance européen et des éléments d'état
de droit qui était suivi pour les
différents pays pour la pologne quels
critères de l'indépendance de la justice
de la justice et donc là il y à un
dialogue qui a été intense ces derniers
mois sur essentiellement des procédures
de destitution de certains juges et la
mise en place donc de chambre
disciplinaire qui ont procédé à ces
destitutions et comme vous le savez
l'expression sur la hiérarchie des
normes de la cour suprême à polonais sma
je pense que ce sujet qui
essentiellement le le fait d'une
discussion entre la commission
européenne et la pologne est un sujet
qui peut avoir
un débouché dans les prochains mois et
qui peut se régler dans les prochaines
semaines et les prochains mois parce que
il ya eu suite aux différents échanges
en particulier de la chancelière de
moi-même et de la présidente de la
commission européenne du président
michel une avancée avec un engagement
pris par la pologne donc de démanteler
ces chambres disciplinaires et de
restituer ces juges et donc de montrer
que ces conditions étaient bien remplis
je ne sais pas dire aujourd'hui si nous
dirigerons je sais dire qu'il ya un
processus qui est en cours qui me semble
enclenchée avec des progrès mais nous
restons vigilants déterminée et c'est
les prochaines semaines qui nous diront
si ça avance ou pas et ensuite une
procédure qui elle est enclenché depuis
plusieurs années sur les bannières plus
large le sujet de l'état de droit
article 7 est donc celle ci elle je ne
pense pas qu'elle donnera lieu à des
avancées substantielles dans les
prochaines semaines sauf s'il ya des
initiatives prises par la pologne pour
répondre aux demandes très précises
faite par la commission européenne et
donc je pense en effet qu'elle
continuera à durer je vous entends
totalement sur le fait se dire que tout
ça donne le sentiment duré trop
longtemps
je pense qu'on peut avoir des résultats
encore une fois à court terme la grande
difficulté dans laquelle on est plongé
si nous sommes honnêtes avec nous mêmes
c'est que tout notre système a été pensé
comme si cela n'arriverait jamais
parce que nous n'avions jamais imaginé
qu'on puisse avoir une remise en cause
de ces principes là de ces normes
pendant des décennies l'europe sur ses
principes s'est construite comme
allant constamment comme reposant sur
une téléologie je dis bien téléologie
parce que tu as font déjà dit théologie
et après ça me ferait beaucoup de
problèmes et nous sommes en particulier
un jour de la laïcité et ne tenons à ce
jour important donc je dis bien
téléologie mais l'europe ont toujours
pensé nous fait que on allait vers une
europe de plus en plus justement
respectueuse de ses droits fondamentaux
et qu'on allait vers une amélioration de
ses droits nous avons depuis plusieurs
années un mouvement que nous voyons à
l'oeuvre qui travaillent plusieurs pays
et qui d'ailleurs est aussi à l'oeuvre
dans le nôtre qui est le fruit de
certaines formations politiques mais qui
travaillent nos sociétés de remise en
cause de ses valeurs
et on ne peut pas faire comme si de rien
n'était donc il faut d'abord je dis
toujours un être intraitable avec nos
valeurs évidemment qu'ils aient des
procédures qu'elle ait des effets utile
deux qu'on s'interroge quand même sur
pourquoi tout cela devient quelque chose
se passe quand même dans notre europe
qui fait qu'il ya un ébranlement des
consciences et qu'on remet en cause ce
qui nous semble être une évidence j'ai
pas la réponse à ça mais ne faisons pas
comme si c'était un problème secondaire
parce que les dirigeants dont on parle
sont des dirigeants démocratiquement élu
par leur peuple
la troisième chose moi j'ai un objectif
quand même c'est d'essayer de convaincre
ses dirigeants mais surtout leurs
peuples et de ramener tout le monde à
nos valeurs en ayant fait cet examen
politique culturelle de profond que nous
devons faire en europe et 1 mais en
gardant notre unité je pense que toutes
celles et ceux qui disent il faut couper
quand ça va pas prenne une responsable
de responsabilité est ce qu'on pense que
la réponse à tout ça c'est de dire la
pologne n'a plus rien à faire dans
l'union européenne moi je ne pense pas
et donc je pense qu'il faut être très
dur avec les dirigeants les forces
politiques évidemment les actes qui ne
sont pas conformes à nos principes il
nous faut en parallèle tout faire pour
combattre ses idées mais en profondeur
dans le substrat de la vie de la nation
et comprendre comment tout ça peut être
venir et être défendue par certains
concitoyens européens il nous faut tout
faire pour quand même garder cette
europe unie
sur votre deuxième question
je vous remercie de l'avoir mis d'abord
hypothétique cette présidence française
nous n'avons pas nous n'avons pas choisi
le calendrier
c'est comme ça et ce calendrier qui plus
est on ne l'a pas choisie il était
difficile de l'anticiper il ya plusieurs
années sinon d'ailleurs nous mêmes au
début où nos prédécesseurs l'aurait
bouger parce qu'il est le fruit aussi de
la mise en oeuvre du bric site qui a
déréglé lors de nos présidences bon est
ce que pour autant
nous avons essayé de bouger les choses
mais ceux qui viennent directement avant
ou après avaient eux mêmes des périodes
électorales et donc il nous faut tenir
notre rang notre rôle avec l'esprit de
responsabilité en considérant que c'est
la france qui est aussi une continuité
que les sujets dont on parle sont ceux
qui sont poussés depuis plusieurs années
qu'ils sont intérêts de la france et de
l'europe et donc je veillerai à faire
cela au demeurant j'essaie de le faire
depuis quatre ans est ce que toutes les
sensibilités politiques
qui dans le discussion démocratique qui
s'organisera en france dans les
prochains mois
on l'a même perception de cet agenda à
coup sûr non et donc
ça ce sera le je dirais la vie
démocratique de notre nation qui à
partir de la fin du mois d'avril dira
sur ces sujets les positions que tiendra
la france mais je pense que cette
présidence française nous pouvons la
tenir dans un cadre qui est le nôtre
c'est à dire en tant que présidence qui
ne fait pas pour autant la politique des
27 peut-être que la politique de la
france changera à coup sûr la france
restera la france en tout cas je ferai
tout pour et je le ferai durant les
prochains mois jusqu'aux échéances
électorales qui sont les nôtres croyez
le bien à côté de ça nous avons organisé
les choses pour que d'abord évidemment
la réserve soit respectée conformément
aux lois en vigueur pour que nos
fonctionnaires
nos équipes puissent continuer de vrais
servant l'état durant toute cette
période et gouvernement a aussi organisé
de manière régulière des consultations
transpartisane compris avec les
parlementaires européens pour veiller à
ce qu'ils aient une juste information et
concertation durant cette période et que
ce soit apaisée c'est important
pour nous et on me dira
bonjour le président laurence benamour
agence france presse
un peu en miroir à la question de ma
consoeur je vous demandais si les choix
que vous prenez pour l'europe ne vont
pas finalement contraindre limitée
encadrer l'action d'un futur
gouvernement en 2022 par exemple
vont-ils empêcher une politique
radicalement différentes sur sur les
étrangers sur la construction de
nouvelles centrales nucléaires sur un
retour à la rigueur si vous ne parvenez
pas à faire oublier les 3% de maastricht
merci
sur ce sujet je vous réponde rapidement
parce que je ne vais pas répondre non
plus xx x
j'ai dit et je vous le redis
le mandat que m'ont confié les
françaises et les français je l'exercé
ré jusqu'au dernier quart d'heure
et donc les défis qui sont les nôtres
qu'ils soient sanitaires qu'ils soient
migratoire qu'il soit énergétique
implique des choix
dites-moi la dette à laquelle il faut
s'arrêter de travailler démocratiquement
c'est la fin du mandat et donc je
travaillerai jusqu'à la fin du mandat et
il ya parfois des choix importants qu'il
faut faire quelques semaines ou quelques
mois avant la fin d'un mandat si je suis
devant cette situation je le ferai et
donc étant président démocratiquement
élu avec un terme j'agirai en cette
condition jusqu'à ce terme
bonjour monsieur le président julien
lécuyer du journal la voix du nord une
petite question qui concerne à toutes
les toutes les régions qui seront
intéressés par la reconquête
industrielle vous avez rappelé récemment
que notre région au niveau de france
avait donné beaucoup à l'industrie de
ses paysages et de ses vies et à l'heure
actuelle elle a en effet des grandes
attentes autour d'elle de la refondation
industriels des grands pôles de
compétitivité et la question que se
posent certains des salariés qui
occupent ces ces industries à l'heure
actuelle c'est de savoir si
dans l'avenir à l'avenir dans les mois
prochains et ce que vous serez le
fervent défenseur du champion européen
même s'il est à l'extérieur des
frontières de la france ou bien vous
ferez vous l'avocat de la terreur
français pour permettre aux salariés
français de conserver dans un coin merci
alors d'abord nous bâtissons une
politique française pour
être crédibles sur cette reconquête
industrielle
depuis maintenant quatre ans et demi
nous avons mis en oeuvre une politique
macroéconomique et microéconomique pour
aller en ce sens ce poids des mots leur
reconquête industrielle sont des choix
des actes ce sont les choix budgétaires
et fiscaux que nous avons pris il n'y a
pas de conquête industrielle si ya pas
de financement de notre industrie et
donc les choix que nous avons pris sur
le plan de la fiscalité au début du
quinquennat la baisse de l'impôt sur les
sociétés la baisse de la taxation du
capital ont permis de retirer
des investissements et des entreprises
en france et d'enrayer la
désindustrialisation
depuis deux ans nous avons enrayé une
baisse de notre industrie qui datent et
imaginer le de 12 années douze années
nous avons vécu deux années de baisse de
l'emploi de l'investissement industriel
nous avons mis fin à ça depuis deux ans
c'est le fruit de notre travail c'est
ensuite le travail filière par filière
d'investissements publics
d'investissement dans la formation de
nos chômeurs comme de nos travailleurs
et donc cette politique française elle
porte ses fruits et elle a commencé a
permis de réindustrialiser les chiffres
on compte encore d'ailleurs été il ya
quelques jours mise en exergue qui
montre que n'avons jamais recréé autant
pas simplement d'emplois mais de projet
industriel que ces derniers mois le plan
de relance européen nous a aussi permis
de le faire pour vous dire que l'europe
ne conduit pas forcément à choisir entre
l'europe et la france et donc grâce au
plan européen que nous avons négociés on
a eu des financements de l'europe qui
nous ont permis à travers
france relance et maintenant france 2030
de bâtir des projets d'aller beaucoup
plus vite la région de france en a
d'ailleurs largement bénéficié c'est
grâce à ces crédits que nous avons pu
attirer plus vite des projets de
batteries par exemple électrique à doué
ou d'autres sujets très concrets et qui
crée d'emplois industriels ou qu'ils
maintiennent
grâce à ces projets européens qu'on peut
bâtir des nouvelles filières
agroalimentaire etc etc nous aurons
ensuite des alliances comme je le disais
avec parfois des champions a amené nous
défendrons la france partout mais
parfois il y aura des gros projets
européens des gros investissements
européens qui iront sur tel ou tel site
qui n'est pas forcément français ça
n'interdit jamais de défendre des
champions français aussi et d'autres
projets mais nous ne pouvons pas
évidemment considérer que l'europe
serait due à la france donc pour vous le
dire clairement
c'est une politique qui est d'abord
nationales si vous n'avez pas le bon
contexte macroéconomique ce n'est pas
l'europe qui fait votre travail à la
place deux d'ores et déjà l'europe nous
a permis d'accélérer et de développer de
la réindustrialisation 3 ce sera dur en
même temps là encore grâce aux
financements européens nous aurons
plusieurs de nos champions qui seront
financés ou qui se créeront dans votre
région et ailleurs dans la batterie dans
le cloud votre région est ô combien
d'ailleurs un des champions de
l'infrastructure du club avec ovh
et nous continuerons cela et nous aurons
aussi des financements européens sur des
grandes alliances certaines auront des
sites en france d'autres non mais même
quand il y aura des sites hors de france
nous empêchera pas nous avec nos propres
financements nos propres politiques
évidemment de continuer de développer
d'autres acteurs et leur laisser leur
chance n'aura pas de choix à faire
bonjour monsieur le président dans les
liasses trucks france télévisions
première question l'europe s'est endetté
a fait un emprunt commun pour financer
le plan de relance sur le co vide est ce
que vous souhaitez que les vingt-sept
fasse d'autres emprunts communs sur
d'autres financements que le coc vite
bref est-ce que vous souhaitez
pérenniser ces financements commun est
ce que vous avez l'intention d'en parler
avec olaf scholz qui vient déjeuner avec
vous demain deuxième question valérie
pécresse et d'autres candidats de droite
principalement veulent réviser la
constitution pour que la france puisse
s'affranchir du droit européen surtout
sur le sujet migratoire qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
merci alors sur les
sur les financements comme un dû
commencer à y répondre à votre question
tout à l'heure à votre à votre confrère
c'est trop tôt pour dire s'il nous faut
aller beaucoup plus loin faut déjà
utilisé pleinement l'enveloppent qui est
la nôtre nous avons fait un pas
historique
d'abord en décidant du principe de
financement commun et d'un endettement
commun et solidaire sur les marchés ce
qui était un débat tabou jusqu'à ya un
an et demi et nous avons défini une
première enveloppe ne tombons pas dans
ce qui est parfois le défaut français
qui créent d'ailleurs du coup de
l'angoissé nos partenaires qui est dire
avant même de la savoir si on utilise
bien comment ils utilisent on en demande
plus parce que ça donne le sentiment que
au fond la dépense est quelque chose qui
se crée soi même je pense qu'il faut
d'abord affiner notre stratégie
industrielle telle que je l'évoquais l'a
chiffré à voir le même chiffre en europe
1 regardez aussi nos dépenses en matière
de défense sur cette base là à voir un
consensus européen sur nos besoins aussi
en matière d'accompagnement social de
nos transitions climatique
d'investissement climatiques et c est
sur cette base on saura dire ce dont on
a besoin mais ça n'est plus un tabou et
donc peut-être qu'il nous faudra aller
plus loin mais il faut mieux le faire en
sachant pourquoi mais sur quelles bases
quand on procède comme ça on arrive à
convaincre les autres c'est exactement
ce qu'on a fait au mois de mai dernier
ce que je vois simplement c'est que nous
serons sans doute confrontée à ce besoin
parce que le monde dans lequel on vit je
vous le dis pour moi c'est pas un débat
entre les je dirais les pays qui sont
dépensiers ou pas dépenser comment le
vivez avant on doit sortir de cela pour
regarder le monde au fonds on a vécu
pendant des décennies la guerre civile
budgétaire et financière comme on
l'avait vécu avant sur d'autres plans
maintenant nous devons comme on l'a fait
à chaque fois regardez l'europe à
travers le monde et nous pensé comme une
puissance de financement du modèle de
croissance moi je le regarde à deux
zones qu'est ce qu'on veut faire on veut
une europe qui créent des emplois si
c'est l'europe du chômage ce sera
l'europe de la guerre c'est notre
premier défi créer des emplois créés d
emploi créé des emplois
l'europe des années 1930 et une europe
qui de fait divisée avait choisi la
déflation c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé regardez les choix budgétaires de
pays qui n'était pas alors unis mais qui
dans les conflits qui ont existé les
choix politiques nationaux sont allés
vers des choix déflationniste cette
europe a construit la guerre parce
qu'elle avait d'abord bâti le chômage et
la défiance nous devons avoir une europe
qui regarde l'avenir l'optimisme et qui
donne la confiance à notre jeunesse qu
on s'est embrassés nos défis et créer
des emplois l'europe du plein emploi
elle est décisive si on veut garder une
europe de la prospérité et de la paix et
donc s'il faut investir
100 milles pour cela il faut le faire
c'est un choix politique et
existentielle nous ne savons pas
aujourd'hui de chiffrer mais on voit
bien que parce qu'on l'a fait il ya un
an et demi
la france
grâce à ses réformes au niveau national
mais grâce aussi à cet élan européen
elle à son niveau de chômage le plus bas
depuis 15 ans 15 ans et elle sort d'une
crise qui est beaucoup plus dur que la
crise financière de 2008 2010 et donc
faut continuer ce chaude ce soit de
croissance est plein emploi la deuxième
chose et géopolitique regardez ce
qu'investit la chine regardez ce qu'ils
investissent les états unis d'amérique
quand ils investissent sur leur
transition énergétique sur l'heure
numérique cent mille
l'europe ne peut pas dire j'ai investi
et dire on va faire des champions c'est
pas vrai et donc quand on chiffres
chaque filière si on dit on veut être
les champions de l'hydrogène moi je suis
pour surtout que nous on produit de
l'électricité très décarbonée on est
champion de l'hydrogène que mettent les
autres on veut être champion du
numérique quels sont les investissements
sur les grandes solutions numériques
font aujourd'hui les chinois des
américains et qu'est ce qu'on fait en
europe 1 c'est ça qu'il faut regarder
parce que la compétition est
internationale
voilà cédé pour moi les deux grands
sujets qui doivent éclairer nos choix je
ne me prononcerai pas aujourd'hui en
tant que président de la république sur
des vous le comprendrez bien sur ces
sujets de campagne je n'ai pas fait le
choix de proposer une révision
constitutionnelle à nos compatriotes je
pense que nous avons en europe et ainsi
nous savons bâtir un pacte justement
migratoire efficace la possibilité de
manière très pragmatique
de construire les solutions d'abord pour
aider les pays d'origine et de transit
mieux protéger nos frontières et avoir
des règles communes moi je suis pour le
pragmatisme en la matière et donc c'est
sûr ce pragmatisme que dans les
prochains mois j'essaierai d'avancé sur
les solutions utiles et après il
appartient à chacun d'éclairer ce débat
faut pas en faire un débat je dirais
tabou pour les uns au totem pour les
autres sur ce qu'est la constitution
faut que ce soit précis simplement pour
savoir ce qu'on veut modifier exactement
et pour faire quoi et à quelle échelle
utile
oui bonjour catherine chatignoux les
échos c'est une question sur l'autonomie
stratégique
il ya eu au début de la crise sanitaire
le gouvernement à demander à des
industriels est fabriqué des masques
dont la france manquait or un an et demi
plus tard on se rend compte que la
production est bien là mais elle n'est
pas écoulé parce que les produits sont
trop chers et qu'on continue à importer
massivement des masques de chine donc
est ce qu'il n'ya pas un problème là de
compétitivité est ce que ce n'est pas
même si c'est un peu anecdotique les
limites de cette indépendance
stratégiques alors sur ce sujet d'abord
vous avez raison de dire que pendant des
années en france et ailleurs nous avons
construit des dépendances parce que nous
avons pensé notre europe comme un marché
ouvert dans un monde en paix
et donc nous avons en quelque sorte
considéré que
l'être suprême était le consommateur
européen
moi je considère que
semer de l'édifice européen c'est le
citoyen et la citoyenne européenne
c'est-à-dire une personne qui est tout à
la fois qu'ils consomment mais qui
produit et qui veut être au coeur de
choix démocratique
décider librement librement
souverainement tout ça nous a conduit à
repenser la souveraineté est en effet
pour avoir visité plusieurs usines de
production de masques et nous expliquer
comment méthodiquement une europe
ouverte qui ne regardent pas où elle
fait ses achats et où le simple critère
qui est regardé c'est le moindre coup
fini par dire il ya personne qui a le
moindre coût que les chinois et ont créé
cette dépendance nous l'avons nous avons
deux fêtes créé des capacités de
production parce que tout était fermé
venant de la chine
et nous sommes en train de changer les
comportements est-ce que ça va assez
vite à mes yeux non il ya eu parfois sur
certains sujets d'achat des nouvelles
qui n'étaient pas tout à fait juste
dans ce qui était dénoncée donc les
ministères compétents ont pu corriger
ces nouvelles quand elle sortait par
contre il est vrai que plusieurs
acheteurs publics ont privé ont parfois
repris leurs habitudes alors qu'il
reprenne une partie d'habitude ça n'est
pas illégitime parce que tout le monde
doit faire des choix et il ne s'agit pas
de faire de l'europe un continent
autarcique car cela ne fonctionne pas
non plus nous restons un continent
ouvert pour deux raisons d'abord nous
devons continuer trouver un équilibre
entre parfois l' acheter le moins cher
possible garder la souveraineté sur
certaines productions et parce que nous
mêmes nous avons l'ambition d'exporter
vers d'autres régions notre agriculture
que nous défendons elle exporte en
dehors de l'europe elle a besoin d'être
défendus hors de l'europe donc faut là
aussi savoir raison garder par contre
nous ne sommes pas assez rigoureux dans
l'achat européen c'est pourquoi d'abord
premier ministre à ma demande depuis
plusieurs mois procéder à un passage en
revue des achats non seulement
ministériel mais de tous les acheteurs
publics car vous savez que l'achat
public est extrêmement fragmenté
beaucoup d'acheteurs publics s'en fait
beaucoup de collectivités et les règles
sont dans un établissement qu'on appelle
le gab pour que à côté de la simple mais
c'est un moindre coût tout en respectant
ce que notre droit pénal a mis aussi
comme contrainte légitimement dans les
achats publics un acheteur public ne
fait pas ce qu'il veut je tiens ici à le
dire parce que très vite sa
responsabilité pénale est mise en jeu et
le favoritisme et traquer à juste titre
c'est le fruit de dan et aussi de
politique de transparence et la lutte
contre la corruption mais tout en
respectant ces règles de favoriser
l'achat européens nous pouvons encore
faire mieux les choses se sont beaucoup
améliorées mais on doit encore aller
plus loin et au niveau des européens
nous portons cet agenda on est en train
de le porter ou non au niveau du fond
européen de défense où je peux vous dire
depuis trois ans c'est un combat
homérique pour convaincre certains de
nos partenaires de dire on a mis de
l'argent dans un fonds européens on va
pas financer des équipements qui sont
faits hors d'europe mais vous avez des
pays qui défendent d'autres choix et
donc c'est un agenda qu'on continuera à
porter en présidence donc ce monde est
un parfait il ne sera jamais totalement
fermé pour de bonnes raisons mais on va
continuer de l'améliorer mais
stratégiquement il faut aller vers
beaucoup plus d'achats européens et par
voie de conséquence aussi français mais
pas que français pour permettre de
défendre notre souveraineté industrielle
mais parfaitement raison
la parole est à jean quatremer du
journal libération qui est en
visioconférence depuis bruxelles
oui bonjour est-ce que vous m'entendez
ou est clair
c'est parfait
ok donc je pose la question je faisais
là
c'est un sujet très bruxellois le
parlement européen va élire son nouveau
président en janvier et en application
de l'accord politique de juin 2019
conclu entre les socialistes les
conservateurs et libéraux de renaissance
un conservateur ppe dont doit succéder à
la socialiste or le le présenter la
candidature de roberta mais cela les
malaises qui combat le droit à
l'avortement et puisqu'elle est élu au
parlement mais qui vient mais de
s'abstenir sur une résolution demandant
la criminalisation des violences faites
aux femmes le gros politique renaissance
auquel appartient la limite en large
sans le prêt à voter en sa faveur une
présidente du parlement européen qui
s'oppose roi des phares exactement 40
ans après l'élection simone veil est le
symbole de l'ordre des valeurs que vous
venez de fermement défendre les gens
conflit pour une seconde question si
vous permettez
sont l'espace de libre circulation
schengen que vous qu'elle vous semblez
particulièrement tenir n'est plus
aujourd'hui qu'à un souvenir les
contrôles aux frontières notamment
aériennes et ferroviaires sont devenus
la règle
que ce soit pour des raisons de sécurité
des raisons sanitaires des routes sont
rebelles physiquement condamné par
exemple à la frontière espagnole
pourquoi ne pas assumer clairement le
retour aux frontières internes merci
merci beaucoup
c'est des questions directes je
reconnais votre esprit piquant
sur la première question
je vais vous répondre pour ce qui me
concerne et faire peut-être une
clarification institutionnel pour ce qui
me concerne je défends et défendrai
toujours avec la plus grande force le
droit des femmes et en particulier le
droit des femmes à disposer librement de
leur corps est donc partout en europe il
y à des forces politiques qui remettent
en cause ce droit qui le fragilise je
ferai tout ce que je peux pour mieux
poser en respectant la souveraineté de
chaque état membre mais en le faisant
aussi dans notre pays parfois ces voix
s'élèvent
c'est un combat que j'ai toujours mené
c'est un combat celui de l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes que j'ai mis
aussi au coeur de ce quinquennat que
j'allais me avant que ce soit un sujet
de controverse et un sujet si médiatique
je tiens ici à leur préciser quand
d'ailleurs parfois les mêmes qui sont
les plus virulents aujourd'hui pour le
défendre m'expliquer je m'en souviens
comme si c'était hier en octobre 2016
que j'étais bien anecdotique à parler de
la sécurité des femmes dans les
transports à strasbourg en faisant le
compte rendu du premier débat que
j'avais fait avec la république en
marche j'ai de la mémoire et donc sur ce
sujet je suis cohérent et je le serai
jusqu au bout
simplement je suis président de la
république française ce faisant je ne
suis pas le chef d'une formation
politique et je ne suis encore moins le
chef d'un groupe parlementaire européen
et donc de là où je suis je défend ses
valeurs avec force et je souhaite que
toutes et tous qui sait défendre dans
les enceintes où il on allait porter qui
en ont qui au nom de combat commun
mais je pense que c'est aux
parlementaires européens
de choisir leur président et leur
présidente
j'espère qu'ils le feront avec l'esprit
de cohérence et j'espère qu'ils seront
en fidélité avec les combats qui sont
l'honneur
je veux d'ailleurs dire ici que sur ce
combat
de nombreux membres du ppe et d'ailleurs
c'est parce qu'ils ne vous fait pas dire
que vous avez pas dit et je précise ici
je pense que vous serez d'accord de
nombreux membres du ppe sont aussi
d'accord avec ses principes et les
défendre avec autant de force que moi
sur votre 2ème sujet
ce que vous décrivez est le risque
auquel nous sommes confrontés peut-être
même la réalité qu'à certains moments
ces dernières années nous avons vécu
schengen est un espace qui s'est
fragmentée
à cause de la menace terroriste
à cause
de la tension migratoires à cause de la
panique sanitaires à trois reprises
est ce que c'est une fatalité je ne
crois pas d'abord sur la question
sanitaire vous aurez noté que la france
n'a jamais été sur ce sujet parmi celles
et ceux qui ont procédé à des mesures
unilatérales de fermeture ou qui ont été
vers des politiques non coopératifs
m'a toujours tenu à une cohérence
européenne
ensuite la france par contre a remis des
contrôles aux frontières dans la lutte
contre le terrorisme et les a toujours
et contrôle du coup aux frontières
massivement et compris sur des sujets
migratoires dans les zones frontalières
vous avez raison
en matière de lutte contre le terrorisme
c'est à adapter en fonction de
l'évolution de cette menace cela
existera toujours cela ne se substitue
pas à la coopération entre nos services
de renseignement une justice le premier
ministre lui-même il était il ya
quelques jours d'ailleurs en belgique
pour travailler sur ce sujet avec les
ministres compétents
la rénovation du code que la commission
présentera dans quelques jours ou
quelques semaines permettra d'ailleurs
de clarifier ses règles de même sur les
sujets migratoires mon souhait quel est
il c'est qu'on est justement un espace
schengen qui soit plus efficace et
cohérent plus efficace à ses frontières
extérieures et plus cohérents en interne
pour éviter ce que vous dites en raison
de la crise migratoire
est donc ce que je propose me
semble-t-il est un élément de réponse à
ce que vous dites pour ne pas faire
l'acte de décès de ce qu'est schengen
cela suppose de repolitiser
dans le bon sens du terme cet espace de
dire ça doit être un sujet de
préoccupation de concertation de
coordination permanente des ministres
compétents ça veut dire ensuite nos
frontières extérieures sont à la
frontière de la pologne de l'italie ou
l'espagne ou la grèce ce sont les
frontières européennes
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on n'a pas des
règles un contrôle strict un engagement
commun et bien rentrer sur le sol
européen des femmes et des hommes qui à
cet instant sont soumises à des règles
qui deviennent très hétérogène ils
nourrissent ceux qu'on appelle les flux
secondaire et la défiance entre les
états membres et ses mouvements
secondaire et donc on doit mieux tenir
nos frontières externes
politique de schengen renforcer pilotage
politique et on doit harmoniser nos
politiques d'accompagnement et nos
politiques d'asile et cdci si on fait ça
alors oui sur le sujet migratoires on
peut refaire de schengen un espace
ouvert parce qu on en refera un espace
de confiance et de protection mais ce
qu'on voit c'est que les réseaux
de trafiquants utilisent qui était
devenu une vulnérabilité pour faire de
l'europe un espace de trafic on doit
réagir à cela c'est ce qu'on a fait la
réponse est imparfaite qu'elle ne peut
la réponse pérenne ça n'est que la
rénovation de schengen protection aux
frontières et convergence pour avoir des
règles communes sur ces sujets
frédéric haziza de radiologie monsieur
le président vous venez de faire
allusion à l'humanisme européen aux
valeurs et l'histoire de l'europe alors
dans le prolongement de ce que vous avez
dit je voudrais vous pouvez vous poser
une question sur les valeurs de la
france et de l'europe eric zemmour mais
d'une campagne haineuse une campagne
nauséabonde raciste crypto pétainiste
roland antisémite et révisionniste
il met en avant une haine anti musulmans
autour de la théorie du grand
remplacement ils cherchent à réhabiliter
pétain soi-disant sauveur de juifs remet
en cause le discours du vel d'hiv le
procès papon le discours du vel d'hiv de
jacques chirac et même l'innocence du
capitaine dreyfus alors les thèmes de
campagne du candidat zemmour sont ils
conformes aux valeurs de la france pour
valeurs de la république et aux valeurs
de l'autre
d'abord il n'appartient pas au président
de la république quel qu'il soit deux
qualifiés ou disqualifier un candidat à
une élection à venir
c'est au peuple français de décider
souverainement il y a des règles elles
sont contrôlées par le juge
constitutionnel
pour certaines autres plus technique par
le juge administratif
d'autres fois par le juge
c'est au peuple souverain de choisir
donc je ne me dirai pas si
ce qu'il convient de penser ou pas je ne
dirai qu'une chose
c'est que notre pays est
un vieux pays fait de valeurs de culture
de combat
et qu'il s'est à chaque fois grandi
d'avoir su regarder ces défaites mais
d'avoir su consolider ses valeurs
et aimer la france et respecter les
français
c'est au fond avoir une certaine idée de
la grandeur de la france
c'est respecter la dignité
de chaque française et de chaque
français
parce que c'est ce faisant respecter la
dignité de notre nation j'ai pas
d'autres commentaires à faire
merci
bonjour monsieur le président un seul
fille pas d'alcool mais j'ai une
question qui concerne un pays tiers le
royaume uni est la relation entre
l'union européenne et évidemment la
france
bilatérale a pas que la france vous avez
pas le passé soit y est associé le
royaume uni plus étroitement avec
en matière de défense et sécurité avec
l'union européenne et pourtant il y à un
tel
méfiance entre les deux pays
actuellement et ça semble très difficile
en ce moment d'imaginer un tel dialogue
politique comment qualifiez-vous cette
relation actuelle et quelles sont les
conditions
d'une amélioration et d'un retour de
confiance nécessaire afin de bâtir
quelque chose
plus solide et plus constructives pour
l'europe dans le sens plus large
ensemble merci merci beaucoup
d'abord
la grande bretagne est une grande nation
elle aussi
voisines et amies
[Musique]
et notre histoire comme notre géographie
on n'échange pas nous avons plusieurs
centaines de milliers de françaises et
de français qui vivent qu'ils aiment ce
pays sa culture qui ont construit
leur vie et il y a
plusieurs dizaines de minutes quand même
plusieurs centaines de milliers de
britanniques qui aime autant la france
et qui ont construit là aussi leur vie
ils sont doit pas de le remettre en
cause le fragiliser il ya des désaccords
avec gouvernement actuel cet autre chose
et je veux avoir avant tout à voir ce
message à l'égard du peuple britannique
et voilà notre amitié parce que au fond
et dans la durée rien ne la remettrait
en cause après nous avons en effet
aujourd'hui des relations qui sont
difficiles mais elles sont difficiles
pourquoi parce que le gouvernement
actuel jusqu'à présent et j'espère que
les choses vont changer qu'on peut se
réengager de bonne foi dans un agenda de
confiance fait simplement ne fait pas ce
qu'il dit
il a signé un accord de retrait qui
impose sur la pêche
le tenir des avis de nos pêcheurs d'un
professionnel les désengagements la
journée de demain nous dira aux côtés de
la commission européenne si ces accords
sont bien respectées il ya eu ces
dernières semaines des progrès et je
veux les saluer il ya un réel engagement
sincère et j'espère qu'une nouvelle voie
s'ouvre vraiment je l'espère de toutes
mes forces
on a ensuite ce besoin de travailler de
bonne foi ensemble sur les sujets
migratoire le ministre a tenu une
réponse une réunion parlons importante
s'il ya dix jours calé
si on veut régler cette question de la
migration entre nos deux pays qui est
devenu une question humanitaire nous
avons besoin d'avoir un réengagement
britannique
parce que pourquoi ces femmes et ces
hommes sont là dans ces conditions
terribles parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
l'asile en france nous leur proposons
nous avons créé des centres en dur pour
cela nous amenons des centaines d'entre
eux dans ces centres nous prenons en
charge des dizaines de milliers de repas
tout au long de l'année mais ce sont des
femmes et des hommes qui veulent
rejoindre le sol britannique parce qu'il
n'y a pas de filière légale
d'instruction du droit d'asile fait par
les britanniques parce qu'il ya toujours
un système qui existe depuis des années
80 opaque où le modèle économique
britannique repose sur le travail
illégal d'étrangers si cette situation
ne sont pas réglés par les britanniques
de bonne foi nous aurons toujours ces
situations à nos frontières ou la france
à la bonne volonté de tenir ce point de
passage la réponse allait dans la
coopération britannique comme on dirait
chez vous vous êtes de chez nous
maintenant voudrais-je de dire be my
guest que les britanniques seraient en
gage de bonne foi sur ce sujet
sur les questions de défense elles ne
sont pas remises en cause par le break
site
mais puis-je ignorer que les
britanniques ont été semble-t-il les
ardents promoteurs
d'un contrat qui
a délibérément combattu une vision
française en indo pacifique pour
construire une vision alternative et
exclusive
n'étant pas sans conséquence d'ailleurs
sur la prolifération dans la région asie
pacifique avec des conséquences
peut-être pas totalement imaginé dès le
début bon tout ça ne sont pas des signes
flagrants d'amitié
pour mal mais manier helander statement
donc
j'aime la grande bretagne
j'aime son peuple
j'ai terriblement envie d'avoir un
gouvernement qui souhaite travailler
simplement de bonne foi avec nos
bons soir monsieur le président marie
chanterait pour tf1 lci depuis quelques
jours plusieurs pays ont fait le choix
de boycotter diplomatiquement les jeux
olympiques de pékin divers je parle du
canada du royaume uni des états unis la
choix la france pourrait-elle faire ce
choix prochainement merci beaucoup
d'abord il fait pas ce qu'il faut savoir
raison gardée de quoi parle-t-on
généralement quand on parlait d'un
boycott des jeux olympiques disait on
n'envoie pas nos sportifs on a connu ça
dans notre histoire à moscou ou ailleurs
personnes à travers le monde est en
train de dire on n'en voit pas nos
sportifs enfin j'ai pas entendu
donc on parle quand même deux choses qui
sont beaucoup plus symbolique
juste pour remettre les débats à leur
juste proportion moi je préfère qu'on
travaille avec le comité international
olympique
pour évidemment que les chartes de
protection des athlètes
compte tenu de ce qui s'est passé ces
dernières semaines soit maintenu et pour
que véritablement on aide le comité
international olympique à faire ce
travail avec la chine pour que tous les
athlètes soient protégés pour que les
règles de l'olympisme partout à travers
le monde ce promu ensuite on appréciera
l'évolution de la situation en lien avec
les autres européens avec le cio et je
pense qu'il faut pas politiser ce sujet
surtout ce qu'on sait pour prendre des
mesures tout petit et symbolique
faut être clair sont dit on fait un
boycott complet on n'envoie pas
d'athlètes soit on dit on essaie de
réengager les choses et d'avoir une
oeuvre une action utile comme toujours à
l'international je suis plutôt pour
faire des choses qui ont en effet utile
c'est avec le cio thomas bach et avec le
représentant du cio en chine et avec
toutes celles et ceux qui l'organisent
c'est comme ça qu'on va travailler avec
les ministres et avec nos partenaires
européens et on verra la décision qui
convient de prendre dans les prochaines
semaines en fonction des réponses qui
sont faites et de ce que la cie aux
faits mais laissons
d'abord ne politisent ont pas
l'olympisme ensuite gars dont l'exigence
qui convient que pour que tous les
athlètes à travers le monde soient
protégés et soient maintenues dans leur
indépendance
c'est pas moi qui ai le micro bonsoir
monsieur le président françois-xavier
bourmaud le figaro il ya cinq ans vous
aviez théorisé la disparition du
traditionnel clivage entre la droite et
la gauche au profit d'un clivage
notamment entre pro européen et
eurosceptique est ce qu'aujourd'hui
quand vous regardez le paysage politique
à la veille de la présidence française
de l'union européenne vous diriez que le
clivage entre européens et eurosceptique
s'est creusée dans le pays et que la
droite et la gauche ont disparu j'ai dit
je veux pas tellement de commentaires de
politique nationale
et donc je vais tâcher de continuer je
vois simplement que
nous avons fait la démonstration ces
dernières années que une europe plus
forte plus souveraine plus uni était
bonne pour la france
et que défendre l'europe il ya quatre
ans était quand même plutôt une bonne
chose
nous serions nous pas européen
bon courage pour les vaccins je dis
juste à titre d'illustration
parce que aujourd'hui nous n'avons
toujours pas de site de production sur
le sol national qui produisent de la rn
message et nous avons des grandes
entreprises françaises
qu'ils font dans des sites étrangers
nous faisons du ce qu'on appelle le film
finish nous sommes en train de
développer une filière mais au moment du
début de la crise nous n'en produisons
pas chez nous nous avons en europe et un
bâti une solidarité qui a permis
d'acheter puis de produire en europe et
1 et d'exporter dès le début
moi je suis fier d'être européen quand
je regarde la crise sanitaire parce que
nous nous sommes battus nous avons
innové nous avons nous européens trouver
des vaccins nous avons acheté des
vaccins en européens et nous avons su
nous organiser pour produire ce qui fait
qu'au moment où je vous parle l'europe
et l'espace géographique qui produit le
plus de vaccins au monde nous avons
dépassé les 2 milliards de doses
produites
l'espace qui en a le plus exporté est
donné
c'est quand même beau l'europe et donc
pour la défense de nos compatriotes
vacciner en janvier 2021 sans l'europe
qui pas été possible c'est ça la réalité
nous n'aurions pas pu le faire
nous aurions été à ce moment-là
dépendant d'achat nationaux avec
beaucoup d'incertitudes peut-être de la
non coopération est sans doute ces mêmes
sur ce qu'ils produisaient sur leur sol
de la rn messager seul le regarder pour
eux
tout ça vous donne de manière très
pratique ce que c'est qu'être européen
parfois on a le sentiment d'être
solidaires avec les autres on a aussi
bénéficié d'une vraie solidarité et nous
avons réussi à avoir une politique forte
que la france a promu avec plusieurs
autres et qui nous permet d'être des
vrais champions en france aujourd'hui on
produit des vaccins on assemble et nous
sommes au coeur de cette stratégie voilà
c'est une bonne chose donc je continue à
penser que en effet
promouvoir une europe plus forte plus
souveraine plus indépendante est une
bonne chose nous l'avons montré que ça
reste vrai demain et je pense que quand
on défend l'europe il faut la défendre
complètement folle à corriger pour se
battre contre ces traverses et
complexité bureaucratique parfois ces
dévoiements mais on peut pas dire j'aime
l'europe
mais j'aime pas son édifice juridique
j'aime l'europe mais les traités ne sont
pas applicables chez nous
ça c'est de la drôle de robe dans cette
affaire ça ne tient pas longtemps
donc européen oui je crois que ça reste
vrai il ya des gens qui continuent à la
vilipender
les français jugeront
sylvie corbet society de presse tout au
fond
voilà
vous avez évoqué l'importance des
frontières extérieures de l'union
européenne il ya notamment une crise qui
se déroule en ce moment en ukraine le
président by donne cette semaine a
repris la main les négociations
concernant les tensions avec la russie
est-ce que la seule à sin selon vous la
fin du format normandie est ce que vous
y voyez une forme d'échec européen faire
une médiation et à ce que vous avez des
craintes comme l'eau exprimer certains
diplomates sur le fait que le président
bailly donne pourrait demander à
l'ukraine de donner des gages à la
russie pour pacifier la situation
d'abord je pense que ces deux une très
bonne chose et je l'en remercie que le
président biden est jugé utile de se
coordonner avec ses partenaires
européens avant d'avoir parlé au
président poutine et après je pense est
une initiative qu'on n'avait pas connu
ces dernières années et qui est très
bonne politique qui donne de la
substance à ce que c'est que la relation
transatlantique
donc nous avons eu ce débat avec nos
quatre européens et le président
américain
ensuite je pense que ça ne se substitue
pas cette coordination format qui
existent président biden a lui-même
d'ailleurs dans lé communiqué qu'il a pu
émettre rappelé l'importance de ce qu'on
appelle le format normandie qui je le
rappelle il se forma qui est une
médiation
franco allemande avec la russie et
l'ukraine autour de la table ce travail
continue et il a permis d'éviter ces
dernières années la détérioration et
nous a permis aussi d'avoir des vrais
résultats mais moi je veux saluer à cet
égard d'abord le choix de mettre en
place ce format qui était le choix de la
chancelière merkel et du président
hollande leur engagement puis
l'engagement très fort
ensuite dans la continuité à mes côtés
chancelière merkel qui a vraiment
consacré beaucoup de son temps à ce
sujet nous avons préservé ce faisant une
situation qui aurait pu dégénérer nous
avons obtenu des résultats ici même en
décembre 2019
mais il est vrai que cette situation
demeure très dur instable et que nous
sommes
dans une main un conflit qui demeurent
gelés
est ce que c'est est ce que les
européens ont la possibilité de changer
cela le seul non ça dépend de la bonne
volonté des autres partis et donc notre
souhait c'est de pouvoir réengager en
lien avec le président céline ski que je
verrai mercredi et en lien avec le
président poutine que j'aurai la semaine
prochaine également en ligne
réenclencher ce format est un processus
politique
notre objectif je crois à nous tous
européens et
aussi à nos partenaires américains
c'est d'abord
d'être aux côtés de l'ukraine pour
assurer sa sécurité
ensuite c'est d'assurer une situation
pacifiant la région fait d'être
intraitable avec la sécurité des
européens dans la région et enfin c'est
de continuer à engager un dialogue
exigeant avec la russie parce que soyons
clairs nous sommes tous les cinq
d'accord les quatre européens les
américains sur une chose c'est par un
dialogue exigeant avec la russie qu'on
peut construire des solutions nouvelles
et un processus qui préserve la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et la
pacification de celle ci la pacification
de toute la région et la stabilité tout
notre continent vous noterez que ce sont
des positions que je défends depuis un
petit moment je pense que ça n'est pas
dans l'escaladé des tensions même s'il
faut toujours être exigeant et fermes
sur nos principes on a besoin d'avoir ce
dialogue est d'ailleurs par cette
discussion le président biden a montré
qu'il pensait aussi qu'il fallait un
dialogue avec le président poutine parce
que c'est par ce dialogue qu'on peut
acter nos accords et nos désaccords mais
aussi bâtir un chemin parfois des digues
mais évitez d escalade
bonjour monsieur le président jean yves
baudelot france info est-ce que ce soit
vous ne pouvez pas un peu sur une
confusion institutionnelle
on comprend pourquoi mais vous vous
placez impatiemment devant devant les
français devant vos électeurs un peu
comme le président de l'europe pour les
six prochains mois
rappelons que le président du conseil
européen s'appelle charles michel et que
la france enfin comme ses marques et
derrière vous présidez le conseil de
l'union européenne et pas de l'union
européenne est ce que ce soir vous ne
jouez pas un peu sur cette ambiguïté ce
qu'on peut évidemment comprendre d'un
point de vue politique merci beaucoup
non je d'abord ça n'est pas un jeu
parce qu'on parle de sujets importants
on parle du quotidien de nos
compatriotes
ensuite je pense avoir constamment
rappeler que nous parlions d'un semestre
et il y à une présidence du conseil
européen qui est président charles
michel que vous m'avez entendu cité à
plusieurs reprises avec lequel il était
à quelques instants et si votre question
est de savoir si j'ai vocation à me
présenter pour lui succéder à
l'hémistiche notre conseil puisque j'ai
compris qu'il y avait beaucoup de sujets
d'élections non
et mais il ya un semestre ou en effet la
france aura la présidence tournante la
présidence tournante pour satisfaire
d'un sommet ce donc je crois avoir été
précis
factuel mais le rôle de la france et de
présider les séances mais la présidence
tournante ça n'est pas simplement une
fonction hôtelière c'est une fonction
aussi d'inspiration
c'est une fonction de déclencheur et de
construction de consensus autour de
choses qu'on croit vous l'a vécue aussi
vu quand l'allemagne avait la présidence
on a permis plus construire des choses
parce que vous avez un effet de traction
je n'ai pas attendu cette présidence
vous serez d'accord avec moi pour
proposer essayé de pousser discours de
la sorbonne daté de septembre 2010 est
la france n'avait pas de rôle
particulier
j'ai toujours été je suis cohérent j'ai
défendu l'europe quand beaucoup la
conspuer qu on la faisait siffler je les
portais
j'ai proposé des choses on a d'ailleurs
agi et obtenu des résultats sur la base
de ces propositions la france à la
présider et je serai dans mon rôle
président qui porte cette ce rôle
institutionnel qui lui doit permettre de
construire des consensus indépendamment
des intérêts de la france mais aussi le
promoteur d'un agenda qui correspond à
ce que nous voyons et nous voulons pour
l'europe ya toujours ce ce rôle duhalde
une présidence tournante est allé bien
tournante
une toute dernière question s'il vous
plaît parce que nous arrivons au bout
d'une heure d'utilisation mais se
composer avec cette dernière une suprise
dans mon jour bruno jeudy paris-match
bfmtv 22 heures max ma question concerne
une grande région européenne et ultra
marines et la nouvelle calédonie
dimanche les habitants de cet archipel
sont appelés aux urnes pour la troisième
fois au terme du processus dit de des
accords de matignon
certains nos adversaires politiques
interprète votre silence comme une forme
de d'abandon ou de trop grande réserve
de ces îles pourquoi ce silence
d'abord j'invite chacun
la période conduit c'est toujours
cruel pour celles et ceux qui ont des
responsabilités parfois depuis plusieurs
années
mais j'ai sans doute moi même conclu
concouru en d'autres temps à ces mêmes
injustices quand j'étais dans une autre
fonction troll donc j'ai beaucoup de
distance avec cela mais quand les temps
démocratiques sont là des voix se lèvent
qui font comme si rien ne s'était passé
depuis quatre ans ou cinq ans
oserais je dire que comme président de
la république je suis allé en nouvelle
calédonie chili passer plusieurs jours
je suis retourné pour la première fois
par exemple a ouvert et j'ai tenu un
discours où j'ai été très clair
je crois avoir dit que la france serait
moins belle sans la nouvelle calédonie
ça me semble clair
et ça ne sommes pas l'abandon
après
le gouvernement de la république et le
président ont un rôle à jouer là aussi
et notre rôle a été inédit quant à la
nouvelle calédonie c'est la seule
mandature qui aura eu à organiser les
trois référendum décidé il ya plusieurs
années
le 12 décembre se tiendra le troisième
référendum est le dernier du processus
décidé
et les trois sous ce mandat
conformément exactement à ce qui avait
été écrit est prévue
notre premier rôle sic ils se tiennent
en bon ordre dans de bonnes conditions
de sécurité de sincérité
le gouvernement est à la tâche et j'en
remercie premier ministre le ministre et
outre-mer le ministre de l'intérieur
ensuite c'est que le jour d'après soit
un jour possible quel que soit le choix
fait lors de ce référendum
le rôle du président de la république
n'est pas d'être dans un camp parce
qu'aujourd'hui je parle à des femmes et
des hommes qui sont toutes et tous
dans notre nation et quel que soit le
choix nous aurons à bâtir le jour
d'après
beaucoup oublient dans ces périodes
quels que soient les sujets que ce qui
fait notre force
c'est notre unité
qu'on peut porter
des choix ici ou là c'est respectable
qu'on peut les défendre
mais que nous avons à vivre ensemble et
pour la nouvelle calédonie c'est la même
chose le jour d'après quel que soit le
choix
il y aura une vie ensemble compte tenu
de la réalité géopolitique de la région
et de ce qu'est la nouvelle calédonie et
donc voilà la fonction qui est la mienne
la place qui est la mienne
jusqu'à une dernière question je pense
dernière question
[Musique]
monsieur le président bonjour allison
tassin pour tf1 et lci vous avez annoncé
la fermeture des discothèques
vous avez interdit de danser dans les
bars et dans les restaurants est ce que
ces mesures seront pour vous suffit
quand notamment pour sauver les fêtes
pour noël et puis par ailleurs je me
fais le porte voix de plusieurs de mes
confrères serez vous candidat à la
prochaine élection présidentielle
merci
chacun se souviendra
d'abord que vous fûtes l'ambassadrice de
vos collègues pour porter cette question
donc j'ai compris ces derniers jours
qu'elles étaient parfois obsessionnel
mais
que sans doute pas pour la première fois
dans notre histoire
devant une question alliant la
candidature à la présidence de la
république et les discothèques
ce qui peut-être d'ailleurs
est une invitation à la fête et la
source de promesse et je veux le prendre
comme ça en tout cas
le gouvernement premier ministre et les
ministres ont tué en effet à présenter
des mesures complémentaires dans un
moment sanitaire qui est je le dis très
très sensible mais qui nous avons tous
notre rôle à jouer je ne serai pas long
mais je veux ici vraiment remercier tous
les professionnels à qui on a demandé un
effort et tous nos compatriotes je le
dis parce que j'ai croisé ces derniers
jours plusieurs responsables
d'événementiel de discothèque qui se
sont sentis stigmatisés par cette mesure
or ils ont parfaitement joué les règles
du jeu la difficulté c'est que dans
beaucoup d'endroits où on demandait le
pass annie terre comme on vous l'a vous
me demandez ici comme on l'a tous mes ou
parce qu'ils avaient le pass annie terre
il y avait des moments de social de
socialité de d'interactions très forte
on pouvait boire et manger à proximité
il a été prouvé je parle sous le
contrôle du ministre qu'on pouvait se
contaminer parce que certes le vaccin
permet de réduire très fortement et les
derniers chiffres encore sorti ce matin
sont très bons même sur des variants
mais permet de réduire la circulation
mais pas totalement et dans ces moments
de convivialité qu'il y avait qui dans
les salons qui ôte on serait infectée et
c'est vrai que dans les discothèques où
les bar dansant comme on dit c'est le
cas donc on a demandé un effort pour
essayer de tenir notre stratégie repose
sur la vaccination la vaccination la
vaccination il nous faut continuer à
vacciner les premières doses et
les rappels
l'objectif ça a été rappelé par le
conseil scientifique et plusieurs autres
ces derniers jours sont d'ailleurs très
bon à cet égard nous sommes entre 600 et
700 milles vaccination deux jours c'est
en train de monter et donc c'est une
très bonne chose seuil que nous avait
donné le conseil scientifique qui font
de ce contrôle c'était 500 milles on
était à 700 milles hier donc il faut que
nos compatriotes continuent d'aller se
faire vacciner pour le rappel ou la
première dose c'est la meilleure
protection
y compris ce fameux rappel vous permet
de réduire très fortement la circulation
des variantes les chiffres qu'ils ont
été sortis par les meilleures revues
scientifiques ces dernières heures le
montre encore aux états unis en israël
le deuxième levier c'est le ba
sanitaires la france a fait ce choix au
début de l'été c'est ce qui permet de
mettre beaucoup de contraintes sur les
non vaccinés et d'améliorer le contrôle
c'est ce qui nous a permis d'augmenter
la vaccination de réduire les risques il
faut regarder c'est ce qui nous permet
je vous le rappel de tenir tant et tant
de lieux de culture des changes de vie
ouverte
et puis le troisième ce sont les gestes
barrière complémentaires et dans les
lieux où c'était pas possible c'est là
on a dû faire ces restrictions on va
continuer avec cette stratégie est ce
que dans les prochains jours il faudra
adapter je ne sais pas vous le dire
aujourd'hui
nous évaluerons
en début de semaine prochaine
l'évolution parce que vous savez qu'il
faut toujours un petit peu de temps
d'attentes pour regarder sur l'incidence
il faut quelques jours et il en faut
encore plus sur l'hospitalisation et ils
le font encore davantage sur les soins
critiques on connaît maintenant le
rythme est donc ce qu'on regarde
beaucoup évidemment aujourd'hui ce sont
les chiffres d'hospitalisation et de
soins critiques l'incidence qui est très
forte
à un peu moins de sens que dans le temps
nous n'avions pas le vaccin et les
moyens de protection par contre nous
restons très vigilants pour voir
l'évolution à l'hôpital parce
qu'évidemment nous devons continuer de
protéger nos hôpitaux nos soignants et
dans un temps où il y à d'autres
pathologies qui arrivent les grid les
banques iolite pour les plus petits ou
où les urgences sont là on va
s'organiser les plans blancs ont déjà
été décidées et donc c'est ça qui
conduira à des décisions ou pas
supplémentaire voilà donc je ne sais pas
vous dire si c'est suffisant je pense
qu'en tout cas c'est ce qu'il fallait
faire au vu des informations qui étaient
les nôtres et qui était proportionnée
pour donner de la visibilité et permet
de nous protéger
je ne répondrai évidemment pas aux
dernières questions ce jour mais je veux
simplement vous dire mais c'est normal
que vous la pose y est je respecte tout
à fait et je pense que d'ailleurs si
demain je sais pas où je suis et je suis
dans la nature et que l'un d'entre vous
là vous me la posent ray
et je prends très bien
d'abord je le prends comme un signe
d'affection
un désir caché
presque un appel
plus sérieusement
je pense que
dans le temps qui est le nôtre
il est important que
les institutions continue quand même à
fonctionner de la manière la plus la
plus stable possible
plusieurs d'entre vous ont posé des
questions sur nos valeurs nos principes
quand les vents mauvais revienne
et se lève
il est légitime qu'il y ait des choix
démocratiques que toutes les voix
s'expriment mais le rôle de nos
institutions
et de tenir le pays là où il doit être
ne rien concéder ni au racisme ni à
l'antisémitisme ni à la remise en cause
de nos valeurs ni à la manipulation de
notre histoire et ça c'est à nos
institutions de le faire
avec calme et autorités
et je pense que notre pays on a besoin
dans les temps que nous vivons parce que
nos compatriotes
ont quand même vécu deux années si
difficile
ces moments dans la vie d'une nation ne
sont pas rien
beaucoup ont perdu des proches
dans des conditions humaines terrible
certains souffrent encore de ce qu'on
appelle le qu'ovide l'on vive la
solitude
sont dans des difficultés profondes
économique et social vivent une angoisse
je pense à paris en particulier à nos
jeunes qui est aussi le propre de cette
période
est donc mon rôle en ce moment
est de continuer à agir au service de
notre peuple pour protéger prendre les
décisions parfois difficiles pour
protéger
d'accompagner
et de préserver notre unité
parce que nous en avons besoin et quels
que soient les choix démocratiques qui
sont faits au printemps prochain et ils
doivent se faire dans le calme du plus
grand pluralisme la plus grande liberté
de discussions d'échangés de controverse
car la controverse c'est l'esprit
français
mais la haine c'est la haine de la
france
et donc rôle du président de la
république c'est d'éviter cela donc pour
ce faire
je pense qu'il est bon de de veiller en
tout cas à ce que ce cadre se respecte
et je vous remercie pour votre attention
pour vos questions nous serons amenés à
poursuivre de toutes façons ces échanges
et pour votre temps merci à toutes et
tous
[Musique]
et voilà pour la conférence de presse
l'un des manuels macron la deuxième
depuis le début de son quinquennat le
chef de l'état s'est donc adressé aux
journalistes pendant près de 12 heures
il a présenté ses priorités pour
l'europe à trois semaines de la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne avant de répondre
longuement aux questions de la presse à
quatre mois de la présidentielle
française le sujet de son éventuelle
candidature à sa réélection était
évidemment aussi dans tous les esprits
on retrouve devant l'elysée notre
reporter à katia technique
que retenez-vous cattier de cette
conférence de presse
oui bien il s'agit d'une présentation
très touffu autour des mots clés relance
puissance appartenance avec un travail
qui at il dit a déjà été amorcée au tour
d'un grand nombre de thématiques alors
le président veut passer d'une europe de
coopération à l'intérieur des frontières
à une europe puissante dans le monde
libre de ses choix et maîtresse de son
destin fin de citation pour cela il ya
le maquereau propose de réformer
l'espace schengen en le dotant d'une
organisation politique
il compte également sur le renforcement
des contrôles aux frontières et la
création d'un mécanisme d'urgence en cas
de crise bigras thouars aux frontières
comme dans le cas de la biélorussie
récemment une meilleure gestion des flux
migratoires est attendue ainsi que la
lutte contre les trafics alors un point
clé 1 pour evans et le maquereau on le
savait il compte avancer sur la
politique de défense en construisant ce
qu'il nomme une boussole et stratégique
pour lutter contre les menaces communes
avec le lancement des premiers exercices
militaires communs et le renforcement de
l'industrie européenne de défense il
compte également repenser la relation
avec l'afrique avec des investissements
économiques à la clé et un partenariat
de sécurité contre le terrorisme et la
lutte contre les passeurs tout cela
construit avec les pays africains il
compte également se réengager dans les
balkans occidentaux
il a évoqué également un deuxième grand
axe créer un nouveau modèle européen 2
croissance avec la création d'emplois
dans les domaines de demain comme le
cloud les semi-conducteurs encore la
technologie il compte rattraper le
retard pour être compétitifs face par
exemple aux chinois ou aux américains
avec un cadre budgétaire c'est important
et financier adapté et donc bien sûr des
investissements massifs sur le volet
environnemental quêter a attendu
emmanuel macron compte concilier le
développement économique avec les ongles
et les ambitions climatiques selon lui
avec des solutions de décarbonation elin
ovation il a évoqué la fameuse taxe
carbone aux frontières est également des
règlements pour préserver la
biodiversité jusque dans les
exportations type cacao huile de palme
et n'a pas précisé les mécanismes de
contrôle autre volet important le
numérique il veut en soutenir les
acteurs attirer les talents les
champions de demain il s'est félicité de
l'accord sur la taxation des
multinationales dont évidemment les
géants du numérique un cinquième pilier
est vraiment nommé par m nl macron
proposer des emplois de qualité plus
qualifiés et mieux payés alors on
parlait du fameux salaire minimum ne
sera pas commun à tous les pays d'europe
en tout cas il s'agit selon lui de tirer
tous les salaires vers le haut autre
thématique
il a fini par part cela les valeurs
démocratiques et la culture alors pour
les valeurs démocratiques
le flou était de mise mais il a parlé de
financer le journalisme d'investigation
indépendant également d'adopter une
législation européenne sur les violences
faites aux femmes et puis je parlais de
la culture donc accès à la culture
renforcer et recherche académique sur
l'histoire de l'europe voilà ce qu'il
faut le fallait retenir de ce long
entretien et discussions avec les
journalistes vos conquêtes et actes
techniques en direct de l'elysée
emmanuel macron qui a été évidemment
interrogé sur sa possible candidature à
sa réélection de multiples questions
vous l'avez été posées avant qu'une
question directe la dernière lui soit
adressée il a refusé d'y répondre nous
sommes à présent avec françois poulet
mathis journaliste spécialiste des
institutions européennes vous étiez avec
nous françois fall et mathis avant le
début de l'intervention avant
l'intervention des manuels macron vous
avez donc suivi cette prise de parole
quel regard est ce que vous portez sur
le projet macron pour la présidence
française de l'union européenne qu'elle
visait aube l'europe pour les six
prochains mois
la france est important de noter ce
qu'est emmanuel macron a effectivement
porté deux visions importante qui
apporte un élément nouveau et choix
c'est l'essentiel de cette conférence de
presse sur deux thèmes essentiels d'une
part la souveraineté européenne
autrement dit les solutions la plupart
des solutions ne sont pas des nefs
solutions nationales des solutions sur
des sujets comme l'immigration comme la
santé comme d'autres sont des solutions
européennes pour cette notion de
souveraineté européenne
il a très fortement insisté là dessus à
tel point qu'il a voulu la conforter
pour conforter cette image d'europe
humaniste cette europe humanistes qu'il
défend notamment en étendant peut-être
les changes des jeunes en imaginant ce
que pourrait être un service civique
européen par exemple cette europe
humaniste il l'a défendu avec force qui
selon lui devraient s'opposer à toute
forme de repli national donc ça c'est
très important on retrouve cette idée
souveraineté en matière de défense
puisque là il veut renforcer cette
europe de la défense il n'y a pas en
concurrence de l'otan mais qui vit en
complémentarité sur des sujets
spécifiques de l'europe souveraineté sur
le plan économique ré apprendre à
produire en europe faire en sorte que
nous soyons moins dépendante vu
notamment en ce qui concerne des semi
conducteurs ou d'autres sujets cette
indépendance économique il c'est un des
points essentiels de ce qu'il veut même
temps pour la présidence française et le
deuxième aspect qui est important et je
dirais même très important c'est cette
nouvelle dynamique cette nouvelle
croissance qu'il croit nécessaire de
négocier avec l'ensemble des partenaires
autrement dit la crise sanitaire afin
que l'europe d'avant la crise ne pourra
pas être europe d'après la crise de
manière concrète des règles aussi
spécifique est aussi arithmétique que
les trois pour cent ne peuvent pas être
poursuivis dans cette forme arithmétique
autrement dit
oui à la rigueur budgétaire oui retour à
une certaine forme de rigueur budgétaire
la condition d'accepter certains
principes et notamment que des
investissements fondamentaux pour
l'europe et notamment des
investissements qui vont permettre à
l'europe d'aller vers la décarbonation
eh bien il faut que ces investissements
soient pris en compte non pas comme du
déficit simple autrement dit soyons plus
réaliste et il met en avant le fait que
l'europe a su il ya quelques mois faire
un pas énorme dans la solidité en
imposant et 750 milliards de dhs
emprunts communs c'était un premier pas
et 2e pas effectivement c'est considérer
qu'aujourd'hui la croissance ça doit
être une croissance pour une économie
d'exploser sur lequel il faut accepter
qu'il y ait des dépenses mais à
condition que ça se passe de la dépense
à perte taux sur ces deux sujets je vois
que ça la conférence de presse va mener
une marque je dirais quand même quelque
chose qui m'a marqué dans cette
conférence de presse c'est que il a
établi cette projection sur l'avenir
lampe non pas dans le cas d'une
présidence française qui s'arrêterait
dans deux mois ou trois mois c'est à
dire à la fin de l'échéance de son
mandat il avait clairement mis une
perspective de plusieurs mois c'est à
dire de six mois pour une véritable
efficacité c'est possible cette
présidence française ce qui veut dire
alors on peut en tirer des conclusions
qu'on veut est-ce qu'il sera candidat ça
ne fait de doute pour personne mais
effectivement il pouvait difficilement
annoncé sa candidature
des moments où il fait il prend ses
fonctions de président de la présidence
française de l'ordre donc je crois que
c'est clair et sa dernière phrase montre
bien qu'il est directement impliqué y
compris dans les débats aujourd'hui aux
seules la corse en france elles
notamment le fait lorsqu'il a dit que
lorsque les mauvais vents solaires et
bien à ce moment là il faut savoir
défendre les institutions est ce cette
défense des institutions via 13 facilité
au logement en résonance avec avec la
campagne électorale qu'on a connu et
qu'on connaît toujours en france voilà
donc à d'évoquer les trois axes de la
présidence française du conseil
l'union européenne emmanuel macron a mis
en avant ce triptyque il veut définir
une souveraineté stratégiques
européennes bâtir un nouveau modèle
européen de croissance et enfin bâtir
une europe à taille humaine il a résumé
l'objectif de sa présidence dès le tout
début de son intervention en cette
phrase passée d'une europe de
coopération à l'intérieur des vingt-sept
à une europe puissante vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur c'est donc l'objectif qu'il
s'est fixé en quoi est-ce qu'il se
démarque de ses prédécesseurs européens
qui étaient avant lui à la tête du
conseil de lieu
je pense qu'il ya eu le vent ce qu'il ya
une crise énorme il ya eu à crier
l'économie dans les années 2000 michel
crise cette pandémie qui a fait qui a
obligé finalement l'ensemble les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement à repenser
d'une certaine manière le à repenser son
fonctionnement
et c'est là où finalement il a la chance
d'être à ce carrefour de l'histoire qui
à la sortie d'une crise grave eh bien il
faut admettre qu'il y ait beaucoup de
choses à corriger que beaucoup de choses
à repenser et le dessin qui l'a fait
d'une europe qui non seulement va plus
loin qu'une simple coopération d'aucune
une rampe à un peu plus intégrée et bien
cet emploi il a clairement défini comme
étant son objectif il a voulu ans à se
démarquer toujours par rapport à ce
qu'il me glisser dans la campagne
électorale française pour dire si un
candidat qui véritablement à condition
qu'ils se présentent en saura plus tard
mais qui manifeste sa volonté européenne
et bien ses bras et c'est ce qu'il a
voulu dire et c'est surtout ce qu'il a
voulu dire c'est que l'europe est une
solution ça n'est pas un handicap sur
les grandes options que qu emmanuel
macron souhaite donner à sa présidence
qu'est ce que vous retenez on a noté ce
sommet qui sera organisée entre l'union
européenne et l'union africaine
puisqu'il souhaite réfléchir à bâtir en
avait à la jeunesse africaine y aura
aussi cette conférence sur les balkans
ils souhaitent aussi repenser le cadre
budgétaire européen des accords de
maastricht c'est la fameuse règle des 3%
de déficit ça c'est pour la question
économique et enfin concernant son
dernier axe sociétale il a évoqué sa
volonté d'un service civique européen de
six mois pour les moins de 25 ans ça
peut ce sont des points qui peuvent être
suivis recevoir l'appui des des vingt
sept est un manque de lieux
c'est tout à fait possible c'est l'idée
service civique et qui est né un petit
peu travers des décors des désaccords
qui ont été faits notamment par des
jeunes européens ce service civique
européen s'appuie un petit peu sur
l'expérience très positive de
l'opération erasmus qui après avoir été
le fait des colis étudiants a été
étendue aux apprentis et qui demain peut
être finalement sera étendu à une forme
de service civique qui serait une forme
finalement d'affirmer une identité
européenne pour des jeunes et donc ça
c'est un des points importants je crois
que le point sur l'afrique que vous avez
cité d'abord est très important parce
que je le relis aux problèmes de deux
maîtrises par exemple des flux
migratoires on ne peut pas avoir une
politique européenne de contrôle des
flux migratoires si on n'attaque pas
d'un même moment une politique de
relations avec l'afrique qui est le
problème qui sera le plus le continent
qui posent le plus de problèmes dans la
mesure où ces deux là où risquent de
partir le plus de figures immigrés et
bien une collaboration avec l'afrique
c'est un véritable plan marshall qu'il
souhaite pour l'afrique entre l'europe
et l'afrique d'où l'importance de ce
sommet qu'il a annoncé entre l'europe et
l'afrique donc il relie ces deux choses
et je pense que signer la solution
importante parce qu'on ne voit pas
comment on peut résoudre un problème
migratoire si c'est une grâce pour 17,8
finalement des africains vers l'europe
n'est pas n'est pas jugulée voilà donc
la scène ça c'est un problème il ya
l'autre problème
notre aspect important de sa conférence
de presse je crois qu'ils en matière de
politique étrangère de savoir continuer
à être présent en tant que puissance
européenne pas seulement en tant que
puissance nationaal autres en tant que
l'europe l'europe a d'autant plus de
force n'était entendu que lorsqu'elle
parle d'une seule voix d'où l'importance
sur tous les sujets que ce soit des jeux
olympiques à pékin que ce soit le
conflit actuellement une très bien que
deux choix d'autres sujets sur tous ces
sujets c'est l'europe qui doit être en
première ligne
donc voilà que quelques aspects qui
montre quand même que c'est un véritable
boost européens qu'ils voudraient
essayer de d'impliquer pour la dynamique
des prochains mois des mots très
rappelle très très rapidement si vous le
voulez bien emmanuel macron a été
interrogé sur la crise une chrétienne
elle a déclaré que nous sommes dans un
conflit qui demeurent gelés il a défendu
le format normandie à l'initiative
franco-allemande de notre souhait je le
cite en lien avec les présidents russe
et ukrainien et de réenclencher ce
processus politique être d'abord aux
côtés de l'ukraine pour sécuriser puis
pacifier la situation dans la région il
prône un discours exigeant vis-à-vis de
moscou un dialogue aussi ils rejettent
l'escaladé tension quel est votre regard
sur sur ce sujet
je crois que emmanuel mâcon vont se rend
bien compte ce qu'a jugé comme ça est un
sujet qui peut être explosif qui peut
être extrêmement riche et donc il est
important et il a dit de matières le
dialogue le format normandie c'est à
dire le format qui allie à la fois la
france l'allemagne l'ukraine et la
russie c'est un format qui a eu les
résultats plus ou moins longs mille et
unes des résultats je pense que ce qui
est important qu'il a dit aussi ce qu'il
verra demain je crois du président il
ferait bien et il s'entretiendra
directement avec vladimir poutine donc
dans les deux cas je pense que emmanuel
bach on se pose qu'on continue à vouloir
se poser en médiateur pour essayer
d'éviter toute aggravation de la crise
donc c'est cette multiplication des
contacts que ce soit dans le format
normandie où que ce soit dans d'autres
formats je pense que tant que le
dialogue continu et en particulier avec
la russie on peut espérer effectivement
à éviter que les choses ne s'aggravent
merci beaucoup pour votre décryptage
françois paul et matiz journaliste
spécialiste des institutions européennes
alors comment ont été reçues les propos
d' emmanuel macron jean marc flipo porte
parole à de debout la france et philippa
mazuel président du parti des citoyens
européens en débattent avec nous
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france philippe mazuel
comment est ce que vous avez accueilli
cette conférence de presse qu est ce qui
vous a marqué
bien ce qui m'a marqué c'est d'abord le
certains manques dans cette cette
conférence de presse un manque flagrant
sur la question de la démocratie en
europe parce que nous souhaitons
participer et robin nous souhaitons sur
la partie transnationales nous
souhaitons avancer vers une europe plus
unie d'europe politique mais on voit
bien qu'on peut pas avancer sur la
souveraineté dans beaucoup de domaines
sans accompagner par un processus
politique et je regrette que le
président de la république qui se
targuait de défendre la démocratie
européenne et torpillé le système que
nous avons mis en place en 2014
c'est-à-dire la l'élection comme
président de la commission européenne ce
terreau chef de l'exécutif européen de
la personne qui gagnait les élections
européennes dans qu'en 2019 ces noms de
fait webber qui était le chef de file
des conservateurs européens qui avaient
des élections qui arrivent en premier et
monsieur macron a préféré 20 d'oeuvrer
pour que l'on nomme aux smartphones
airlines ce qui est un déni de
démocratie donc ça c'est extrêmement
rare et je souhaite que en naviguant
remettre sur rails de la démocratie
européenne à partir du mois d'avril
lorsque le président de la république
aura changé de façon à préparer les
élections 2024 que nous ayons vraiment
un président de la commission européenne
où il préside la commission européenne
choisi par les citoyens c'est un point
absolument clé un jour fait réagir vos
os et jean marc flipo après c'est
presque deux heures de conférence de
presse
des manuels macro ans qu'est ce que vous
avez retenu de son de son discours
j'ai rompu reconnu surtout que c'était
un cocktail de projets qui étaient déjà
en route quelques avaient déjà été
lancées par les précédentes présidences
et de déclarations d'intention donc on
est je vois rien de concret je parle
j'ai pas entendu de mesures techniques
concrètes qui pouvait effectivement être
réalisées sur la durée de la présidence
française alors que la présidence
française normalement traditionnellement
est très importante pour notre part nos
deux continents
j'ai remarqué aussi une certaine forme
de constat d'échec de cette de cette
union européenne que ce soit sur des
matières de en matière de défense ce
soit en matière de déficit commercial
soit en matière de numérique il a fait
un peu la liste de tout ce qui
fonctionnait mal dans cette dans cette
union européenne et puis sur son sur son
objectif que vous avez rappelé tout à
l'heure qui est de passer d'une europe
des coopérations inter européenne à une
europe puissance qui assume sa certaine
forme de souveraineté moi je me suis
intéressé à l'europe depuis je suis très
jeune j'ai l'impression d'entendre des
déclarations d'intention 1979 donc on a
pas on n'a pas vraiment on n'a pas
vraiment progressé de ce point de vue là
ensuite j'ai entendu un très mauvais
signal adressé notamment à doha nouveaux
voisins allemands concernant la remise
en question de de la règle des 3% alors
je sais que c'est pas une règle à
laquelle à laquelle je tiens
particulièrement en revanche je trouve
relativement maladroit de l'annoncer
comme ça de cette manière lors de lors
de sa prise de présidence parce qu'on
sait d'ores et déjà que szavay a suscité
une opposition frontale de la part de la
part de nos voisins que ce soit au
niveau de la chancellerie au delà de la
cour de la cour constitutionnelle
déclare au filet pas eu l vous appeler à
plus de démocratie européenne est ce que
l'un des trois axes mise en avant par
emmanuel macron dans sa conférence de
presse bâtir une europe à taille humaine
est ce que ça ne va pas dans ce sens là
je cite les propos d' emmanuel macron
qui souhaite faire de cette présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne un grand moment d'humanisme
européen il évoque une europe plus
efficace plus proche de nos citoyens
plus simple aussi ce sont surtout de
belles paroles qu'est-ce que vous
attendriez pour être plus proche des
citoyens il faut donner la parole aux
citoyens se dire que il faut lors des
élections européennes que des citoyens
puissent choisir le président de la
commission et je dirais même que ils
doivent pouvoir choisir
les commissaires européens il faut
réfléchir à cette façon de
éventuellement délire aussi les
commissaires européens voilà donc ça
c'est un certain point il faut il faut
faire des choses extrêmement concrète
est allé au delà de l'union européenne
d'aujourd'hui il faut essayer d'aller
vers une république européenne entre les
pays qui ont envie d'aller de l'avant
qui ont envie de plus de démocratie et
ça on n'a pas cette personne qui n'a pas
du tout été présenté par le président de
la république
il ya un autre point que je regrette
dans sedan dans cette conférence suivent
on n'a pas tellement parler du social et
on peut pas faire leur des citoyens 100
m plus le social au centre du au centre
du débat alors certes le président à vie
qui a parlé de des revenus d'aller vers
un revenu minimal le minimum pardon mais
je pense qu'il aurait des coq et aussi
de droit du travail européen qui doit
être beaucoup plus harmonisée et si nous
devons commencer par un métier
éminemment européen sur lequel devrions
travailler pour le rapprochement des
salaires ce sont les routiers et
chauffeurs routiers qui constamment si
en europe il a été longuement question
jean marc chipeau de ce premier axe
longo défini par emmanuel macron qui
souhaitent
une souveraineté mettre en place une
souveraineté stratégiques européennes
une europe capable de maîtriser ses
frontières de les protéger il a évoqué
une réforme de l'espace schengen avec de
nouveaux mécanismes de protection des
frontières comment est ce que vous avez
reçu cette proposition
c'est ce que nous réclamons depuis au
moins tout de suite le huis clos du
poignant et candidat à la présidence de
la république depuis 2012 c'est quelque
chose qui sépare et qui devait couler de
fait dès la création de la mise en
oeuvre de schengen en 1995 on est
presque 30 ans plus tard on est toujours
dans la même comment dire dans cette
espèce de l'impossibilité de contrôler
ses frontières extérieures de l'europe
on en a des exemples tous les jours donc
là c'est cette europe là quelques elle
est articulée à l'heure actuelle ne
fonctionne pas est-ce que je ramasse sur
mon constat d'échec donc il faut revenir
selon nous sommes un parti souverainiste
en fait on n'en fait pas mystère donc
nous ce qui nous importe si on reprend
l'ordre des priorités vous c'est que
vous citez ça en numéro 1 nous ne citons
en numéro 1 des priorités l'europe même
qui a été relégué la fin du discours du
président de la république en plus de
sacs des considérations extrêmement
inquiétant selon moi qui vise à à
réécrire une histoire européenne comme
si l'histoire de l'europe n'était pas
déjà et qui n'étaient pas déjà écrite
par qui vise à à à financer des des
journalistes soit disant indépendant
alors qu'il était jugé indépendant par
un organe européen donc ce serait les
formes de journalisme officiel de
l'union européenne qu'on n'irait
subventionnés dans des pays membres
enfin attendez lyon rappelle ça doit pas
devenir l'union soviétique je pense
qu'il faut revenir effectivement à des
principes démocratiques avant de revenir
au niveau du citoyen les français en
rejeter cette europe bureaucratique que
quand nous impose aujourd'hui et qu'on
veut renforcer les françaises sont
exprimés extrêmement clairement contre
ce fonctionnement là pour autant les
français 113 européens et nous pensons
que comme disait le général de gaulle en
fait pas une lettre avec des oeufs durs
mais nations européennes sont désolés
non les européens élisent déjà leur
parlement où pourrais très bien évoluer
selon nous vers une guérilla sion au
parlement européen de parlement de
parlementaires nationaux il retrouverait
une cohérence entre la volonté
démocratique des citoyens qui s'exprime
lors des élections législatives
nationales et qui viennent qui vont
porter les projets de chaque pays au
parlement européen un fils emmanuel sur
ce point de cette souveraineté
stratégiques européennes décrite par
emmanuel macron il a donc été question
de cette réforme de l'espace schengen je
vais vous laisser réagir et il est aussi
revenu sur la politique de défense
européenne il faut avancer sur sur cette
politique n'est pas resté très très
longuement sur ce point la pile a aussi
mis en avant la nécessaire stabilité et
prospérité du voisinage de l'union
européenne indiquant qu'un sommet serait
organisée entre l'union africaine et
l'union européenne ainsi qu'une
conférence sur les balcons quel est
votre regard sur cette première
thématique défend le chef de l'état lors
d'abord sur la sur les frontières je
crois qu'il faut aller véritablement
vers une politique européenne des u9 une
police européenne des frontières et avec
une politique d'acide commune et
évidemment des accords avec les pays
d'origine pour pour pouvoir renvoyer les
personnes qui sont là illégalement en
échange de quoi nous accueillons un
certain nombre d'ennemis camp régulier
sur des emplois
qui sont à pourvoir sur la question de
l'art de la défense
je pense que j'aime je rêvais qu'on
parle d'un concept qui est important
pour le parti citoyen européen patcher
c'est le la diplomatie pacifique c'est à
dire que nous devons aller vers une
diplomatie européenne qui ne soit pas
basée sur la vente d'armes comme on l'a
vu ces jours ci à des à des dictatures
mais qu' on s'impose de de ne vendre des
arcades et pays et démocratique ce qui
ce qui implique que nous devons
développer notre politique européenne
d'armement pour pour avoir une
harmonisation de nos armées et pouvoir
ainsi vendre notre propre matériel en
europe à des pays démocratiques ce qui
manque beaucoup je trouve dans le
discours de monsieur macron aujourd'hui
c'est la sécurité en europe il a parlé
évidemment de l'afrique s'est extrait
important mais il a très peu parlé la
sécurité en europe moi je suis très
inquiet de la situation aujourd'hui je
pense que qu'il faut organiser une
conférence européenne de haut niveau
avec tous les européens et les
américains les canadiens aient constitué
européen évidemment c'est évidemment la
russie l'ukraine le belarus la turquie
de façon à avoir commandé construisons
la sécurité de l'europe de demain est
posée notamment il faut poser un moment
donné le rôle et les lignes de l'otan
qui est un qui me semble être un des
points clés de la difficulté aujourd'hui
avec avec reka russie notamment et dans
cette ce débat sur la sécurité en europe
ne devrions comme en 1973 avec les
accords d'helsinki avoir une corbeille
sécurité une corbeille éducation et
culture une cure bay économie et une
corbeille droits de l'homme voilà c'est
à terme un terme et c'est moi je termine
dessus à terme je crois qu'il faudrait
faire une confédération européenne dans
le domaine économique et culturel
avec tous les pays européens de
l'atlantique à vladivostok jean marc
flipo jaurès réagir à ces quelques
points notamment en ce qui concerne la
sécurité de l'europe et cette question
la politique de défense européenne
maquereau a déclaré vouloir profiter de
cette présidence pour trouver une
boussole stratégique du stade du concept
déjà c'est pas lui qui l'a trouvé un cdi
à d'ailleurs appelé du monde ça a été
proposée par l'allemagne et c'est
quelque chose qui est une tendance
relativement lourde puisque toutes les
armées européennes sont confrontées à
la problématique de l'armée
d'échantillons c'est de là qu'est ce
qu'on fait est ce qu on fait une arme et
d'échantillons comme la france a pu en
avoir par le passé ou est-ce qu'on
s'intègre dans une organisation plus
importantes comme le temps donc ça c'est
un sas est une vraie question personne
n'a la réponse malheureusement
aujourd'hui en fait en europe qu'est ce
que vous avez vous avez deux armées vous
avez dit vous avez l'armée française
vous avez l'armée britannique l'armée
britannique est sortie de l'union
européenne donc on ne peut plus parler
avec elle que bilatérales ou à travers à
travers le commandement intégré de
l'otan et nous avons en plus à des
problématiques industrielles c'est à
dire que nous avons une proximité
industriel avec les britanniques mais
nous avons des visées de politique
étrangère qui sont divergentes avec eux
et nous avons une proximité politique
avec l'allemagne mais nous avons des
intérêts industriels qui sont
radicalement opposés on l'a vu encore
récemment avec le programme skaff où on
va dire le savoir faire technologique de
dassault pour la composante avion de
combat a posé deux arrêts tentera d'être
pillée par là par l'allemagne on a vu le
programme commun sur le char de combat
sur l'avion de patrouille maritime sur
l'hélicoptère de combat tout ça a volé
en éclats donc on peut pas dire vraiment
que l'on soit en voie de d'aller vers
une meilleure intégration mais leur
coopération nous qu'est ce que nous
disons en disant qu'effectivement
l'europe que ce soit pour la défense ou
dans d'autres domaines culturels etc si
l'europe doit être une europe des
coopérations choisie c'est-à-dire que
nous voulons remplacer la commission
européenne par un secrétariat général un
peu qu'un à syndics d'immeubles qui
avait pas s'occuper de ce qui se passe
dans chacun des appartements et que les
pays européens
mais trail en place des coopérations
choisie notamment dans le domaine de la
défense mais effectivement les
investissements nécessaires aujourd'hui
sont très importants et se posera à ce
moment là le problème du financement de
cette politique de défense et évidemment
le la clause des 3% là encore devra être
réévaluée parce que vous comprendrez
bien évidemment que entretenir une armée
comme l'armée française ou entretenir
l'armée maltaise rien contre l'art
geberit ici pas de toute condescendance
mais c'est pas exactement le même niveau
d'investissement
jeu philippe mazuel jean-marc chez pas
et vaka l'instant une coopération choisi
est ce que c'est ce que promet aussi
emmanuel macron quand on l'entend
effectivement abordé enfin déclaré
vouloir aborder la question des valeurs
lorsqu'il sera à la tête du conseil de
l'union européenne
il dit vouloir mener des débats sur
l'état de droit en ajoutant dans la
foulée que ces questions ne sont pas
négociables elles sont existentielle est
ce que cela ne ferme pas le débat
d'emblée avec certains autres états
membres de lieux donc là je suis pas
d'accord avec certains sujet avec le
président d'un but mais sur le celui des
valeurs oui je crois qu'il a raison de
vouloir mettre en avant les valeurs
les valeurs de l'union européenne qui
sont d'ailleurs décrite dans l'article 2
du traité sur l'union européenne elles
sont très claires donc à un moment donné
quand certains états enfin certains
états certains gouvernements remettre en
question ses valeurs il faut être il
faut être assez ferme louis donc là
dessus je pense que c'est que c'est
important
en revanche toujours pour revenir sur le
les citoyens je crois qu'il n'a pas
abordé du tout la question du
multilinguisme il paraît très important
de poser cette question aujourd'hui
parce que comme vous le savez la langue
anglaise a pris une place prépondérante
dans les institutions européennes et là
maintenant que d'autant que le royaume
uni est sorti de l'union européenne je
pense qu'il faut remettre en question
ces sujets là donc certes continue avec
ez angles et là où c'est nécessaire mais
donner plus de poids aux autres langues
rock
français l'allemand l'italien expédiant
un toutou des derniers mois avec vous
jean marc chipeau évidemment 1,82 la
présidentielle la possible candidature
du président sortant à sa réélection
était dans tous les esprits on a senti
les journalistes si elle est un peu à
tâtons avant finalement que la question
ne soit très explicitement poser en
toute fin de conférence de presse on lui
a demandé donc à emmanuel macron s'il
était candidat à la présidentielle
l'année prochaine il a refusé d'y
répondre est ce que ça pose problème
aujourd'hui dans ce contexte
oui ça pose problème parce que pour
l'instant ses campagnes avec l'argent du
contribuable donc le vrai que le
véritable problème est là tout le monde
personne n'est dupe a ainsi demandé à
emmanuel mahfoud ci s'il veut être
candidat à sa réélection c'est un peu
comme demander à un aveugle s'il veut
voir clair donc tout le monde sait qui
va là qu'il va y aller le problème
aujourd'hui c'est que effectivement bah
ya quand même des règles dans une
élection présidentielle notamment de
comptes de campagne et aujourd'hui on
voit bien que d'une part donc du fait
campagne avec l'argent du contribuable
en plus de ça c'est noël avant l'heure
puisque l'on a vu des milliards sortir
de sa hotte par dizaines et les barmen
par centaines et c'est quand même très
très inquiétant c'est il parle là
aujourd'hui de s'affranchir de l'arrivée
des 3% il a déjà commencé à creuser le
déficit budgétaire dans des proportions
absolument invraisemblable on évoquait
au début de l'été un surfinancement de
la perte d'activité en france de l'ordre
de 200% on a doublement financer la
perte d'activité en arrière doit
permettre à 500 milliards d'euros deux
qui sont sortis des caisses françaises
cet argent là dans un contexte de retour
de l'inflation il va falloir le
rembourser c'est les français qui vont
encore devoir mettre la main à la main à
la poche alors que je vous rappelle
quand même que dans le contexte actuel
énormément d'entreprises en france ne
savent toujours pas comment elles vont
pouvoir rembourser les prêts garantis
par l'état qui leur ont été consentis et
ont un avenir
merci beaucoup jean marc flipo porte
parle de debout la france merci à vous
également philippe madrelle président du
parti à les citoyens européens voici
pour ceux
décryptage après la prise de parole des
manuels macron le chef de l'état qui a
donc lancé la présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne elle
démarre le 1er janvier prochain il vient
de tenir une conférence de presse de
deux heures pour présenter les priorités
de son mandat à la tête de l'europe ce
sera pour six mois on en reparle
évidemment à 20 heures dans l'émission
cette fois-ci présenté par grégory
petitjean d'ici là à 19h vous retrouvez
votre émission interdit d'interdire à
bientôt une bonne soirée avec une série
de france
[Musique]
a nouvelle calédonie foule ultime
référendum sur l'indépendance est
maintenue au 12 décembre quel poids
représente aujourd'hui à me moquer
d'elle les indépendantistes dans le
paysage politique en nouvelle calédonie
il ya une progression du oui le peuple
originel concernés par la dépendance il
l'indépendance fils d'adam